vous créerez
merci
merci Boris Filatov mère de nierpro
merci messieurs nous allons passer au
témoignage à présent de ces mères
français qui se sont engagés pour
soutenir l'Ukraine Léonard monconduit
bonjour vous êtes maire de Poitiers mais
aussi co-présidente du groupe de travail
relation internationale à l'AMF à ce
titre vous pouvez témoigner de la
mobilisation très large des mères de
France pour apporter une aide d'urgence
à l'Ukraine d'abord mais pas seulement
oui bonjour à toutes et à tous avant de
répondre à votre question si vous le
permettez je souhaite témoigner de tout
mon soutien au maire qui qui viennent de
témoigner c'est pas si facile que ça de
témoigner après nous qui sommes presque
confortablement installés en France
merci beaucoup d'avoir fait le
déplacement jusqu'à nous votre
témoignage a du sens pour nous et tout
mon soutien est celui je l'imagine tous
les collègues présents dans la salle
pour vous et pour vos administrer pour
vos équipes municipales alors
effectivement dès le début les communes
françaises se sont mobilisées d'abord
pour répondre à l'urgence pour apporter
un soutien matériel autant que possible
et cela a été nous avons organisé les
collectes ce qui a été facilité
notamment par la convention entre
l'Association des maires de France et la
protection civile nous avons organisé
l'accueil de famille ukrainiennes qui
arrivait dans notre ville qui était pour
la plupart des femmes et des enfants
des logements mais aussi beaucoup de
familles françaises qui ont ouvert leurs
bras pour accueillir sa famille et puis
nous avons aussi apporté un soutien
symbolique qui a du sens aujourd'hui il
n'y a pas un Français pas une française
qui ne sache pas que les du drapeau
ukrainien c'est le jaune et le bleu et
ça ça compte ça compte pour nous comme
je l'imagine 50 pour vous après le temps
de l'urgence est venu le temps de la
reconstruction qui ne fait que commencer
mais d'ores et déjà les maires
commencent à prendre des engagements
pour agir pour la reconstruction une
délégation de lui-même européen s'est
rendue cet été en Ukraine dont deux mers
français le maire de Marseille et le
maire de Lyon et une convention a été
signée entre eurosities un réseau de
ville européenne et l'Ukraine afin de
s'engager d'emblée dans la perspective
de la reconstruction durable des villes
ukrainiennes et puis au-delà de ça je
sais que à l'instar de Cannes de
nombreuses villes souhaitent s'engager
dans une coopération plus plus
structurée entre des communes françaises
et des communes ukrainiennes et de même
que pour la reconstruction et bien les
associations d'élus peuvent vous aider
pour structurer des partenariats de long
terme qu'il s'agisse de contribuer à la
reconstruction qu'il s'agisse d'inscrire
la coopération de la centralisée dans un
cadre plus formel quand je parle les
associations il y a bien sûr
l'Association des maires de France mais
aussi si tes Unifrance l'Association
française des communes et régions de
l'Europe dont nous espérons qu'elles
pourrons produire une réponse coordonnée
face à ces enjeux immenses que
connaissent nos collègues maire
ukrainiens et ukrainiennes aujourd'hui
voilà une coopération que donc les mères
français et les maires Ukrainiens
appellent tous de leurs vœux et plus
spécifiquement dans votre ville de
Poitiers comment ça s'est passé vous
avez accueilli notamment bien sûr des
réfugiés jésus-chrignac quelles actions
avez-vous mené bien sûr alors à Poitiers
comme ailleurs nous avons organisé des
collectes nous avons fait face à une
générosité immense des poids de vigne et
des poids de vin qui ont amené des
duvets du matériel sanitaire des
matériels pour les enfants que nous
avons ensuite acheminés nous sommes une
ville universitaire donc nous avons
aussi organisé l'accueil d'étudiants
Ukrainiens dans l'université de Poitiers
afin qu'ils puissent poursuivre autant
que possible bien sûr leur parcours
universitaire et nous avons beaucoup
travaillé avec les associations déjà
présentes sur le territoire qui
travaille pour de réfugiés qu'il soit
aujourd'hui ukrainien mais hier afghan
syrien peut-être demain iranien qui sait
et nous avons aussi bien sûr pu
bénéficier du soutien de l'État français
il faut le dire l'état qui a démontré
combien la France lorsqu'elle le
souhaitent peut accueillir à la fois
avec efficacité et à la fois avec une
grande dignité et ce que nous appelons
nos vœux avec certaines associations
comme l'association nationale des villes
les territoires accueillants c'est que
cet accueil puisse donner que
l'expérience de cet accueil qui n'est
pas fini et bien puisse nourrir la
tradition d'hospitalité et de dignité
qui nourrit les valeurs de la République
française tels que telle que vous avez
été nombreux à l'évoquer aujourd'hui
merci Madame alors effectivement la
solidarité des mers de France
Thibault Guignard maire de
ploeckermitage dans les côtes-deux
Côtes-d'Armor mais aussi co-président
avec Christophe Rouillon de la
commission Europe de l'AMF comment les
villes françaises concrétisent
aujourd'hui cette solidarité avec les
villes ukrainiennes bonjour à toutes et
à tous Léonore la bien résumé cette
volonté de mettre en place des jumelages
de guerre des jumelages qui permettent
d'apporter une solidarité avec les
collectivités
ukrainiennes dont nous avons ici des
représentants et puis la volonté aussi
de se projeter dans des coopérations
plus structurées des coopérations
décentralisées qui durent dans le temps
pour la reconstruction on le sait il y
aura des fonds pour la reconstruction de
l'Ukraine que ce soit de l'Union
européenne ou d'autres grands bailleurs
internationaux et la coopération
décentralisée les collectivités
territoriales peuvent être un gage de
bonnes gestion de cet argent en ARP
portant l'ingénierie de nos communes
l'ingénierie de nos villes mais
aujourd'hui il y a plusieurs questions
qui nous arrivent à l'AMF c'est tout
d'abord comment se mettre en relation
avec une collectivité ukrainienne
lorsque nous n'avons pas de partenaires
alors nous travaillons avec les équipes
de l'AMF à mettre en relation des
collectivités entre elles mais les
structures de collectivité en France et
en Ukraine sont très différentes on en
parlait tout à l'heure avec la
délégation ukrainienne une petite ville
en Ukraine c'est 80 000 habitants moi je
suis maire d'une commune de 4200
habitants donc il est sans doute
intéressant de réfléchir à la
coopération à l'échelle de
l'intercommunalité et peut-être de
rapprocher des intercommunalités
françaises de ville ukrainiennes au
regard du nombre d'habitants dans ces
villes et puis nous avons aussi des des
associations partenaires qui nous aident
dans cette mise en relation il y a une
association française du Conseil des
communes et des régions d'Europe il y a
l'association européenne pour la
démocratie locale Alda il y a aussi le
Congrès des pouvoirs locaux et régionaux
du conseil de l'Europe qui a créé une
plateforme je vous invite à vous y
rendre si vous recherchez un partenaire
qui s'appelle cities forcities qui
permet de mettre en relation des
collectivités ukrainiennes avec des
collectivités françaises et puis
Thibault Guignard il y a aussi ce projet
d'une coopération tripartite France
Ukraine et puis des des maires proches
dans la proximité pour agir directement
envers vos collègues et leur territoire
tout à fait avant la guerre il y avait
peu de jumelage entre la France et
l'Ukraine à peine une trentaine alors
qu'il y a 300 jumelages entre la France
et la Pologne et donc il faut réfléchir
à des coopérations tripartit France
Pologne - Ukraine France - Roumanie
Ukraine pour pouvoir mettre en place ces
coopérations et si vous le permettez je
voudrais répondre à une deuxième
question qui nous est fréquemment posée
à l'AMF c'est mais qu'est-ce que nous
pouvons faire et notamment nous les
petites communes et bien on peut
apporter bien évidemment une aide
d'urgence en par des grandes
associations nationales on les connaît
elles permettent de d'avoir une
traçabilité de l'utilisation des fonds
je pense que il faut arrêter les
collectes de de bien les collectes
là-dessus de vêtements de bien de
première nécessité etc parce que c'est
beaucoup plus simple d'acheter en grande
quantité à proximité de l'Ukraine dans
des pays frontaliers et de livrer
ensuite que d'avoir toute cette chaîne
de logistique du mettre en place la
protection civile en peu de temps pour
acheminer en Ukraine et puis il y a des
initiatives intéressantes je pense à
l'initiative du Collectif stand de
withukrain qui propose d'acquérir des
générateurs c'est à dire des groupes
électrogènes puisque il va falloir
passer l'hiver et pour passer l'hiver il
faut de l'électricité il faut du
chauffage et un générateur pour rendre
service à une famille dont la maison est
coupée du réseau électrique c'est 100
euros un générateur pour installer dans
une école c'est 15000 euros et donc en
fonction de la strate de la commune on
peut s'adapter à l'aide que l'on vous
apporter et donc en allant rechercher
cette campagne qui va s'appeler lumière
pour l'hiver du collectif stand weakley
et bien on peut aider en fonction de ses
capacités financières
et merci d'avoir porté la parole de la
commission rock que vous coprésidez avec
Christophe Rouillon et tous ces projets
que peuvent mettre en œuvre vos
collègues-mères oui nous allons à
présent passer la parole à David Nicolas
vous êtes mère d'Avranches dans la
Manche je précise que c'est important de
ne pas parler trop vite pour faciliter
la traduction afin que et bien bien sûr
vos collègues Ukrainiens puissent avoir
l'intégralité de votre propos au niveau
de votre commune David Nicolas vous avez
aussi lancé des opérations de solidarité
avec l'Ukraine en travaillant notamment
avec les professionnels de santé
racontez-nous
bien bonjour à toutes et tous je salue
nos collègues crâniens et très heureux
de les voir parmi nous à l'occasion de
ce congrès alors en effet
notre exemple n'est pas unique ou s'en
fout je pense qu'on est finalement à
l'image de beaucoup de villes
les suiveurs de David notre président
qui a été un des premiers à signifier
qu'il y avait urgence à se poser la
question de l'urgence sanitaire en
Ukraine et en effet à l'échelle de notre
commune avec la sollicitation
d'associations bien évidemment de
particulier mais aussi à l'invitation de
nos services service municipaux il se
trouve que j'avais autour de moi des
directeurs généraux des services
notamment des cadres qui avaient envie
de donner leur temps bénévolement ce
qu'on le sait les élus sont souvent des
initiateurs mais derrière il y a des
gens qui suivent et bien on a pu
organiser deux missions une vers la
Pologne une vers l'Ukraine de
médicaments en lien aussi avec le
hospitalier de la ville pour pouvoir
répondre à des demandes ciblées donc ça
a été en effet des expériences
intéressantes comme il en a existé
beaucoup d'autres quoi qu'il en soit ça
a permis de mesurer
la grande nécessité qui était celle de
l'Ukraine et qui est toujours celle de
l'Ukraine aujourd'hui et comme cela a
été dit je pense que nous avons le
devoir de prolonger cet effort alors
avec la protection civile avec tous les
acteurs clairement identifiés est
capable de nous aider
merci merci David Nicolas vous parlez de
la protection civile nous sommes aussi
avec François Richet vous présidez la
protection civile merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous
au niveau national l'AMF et la
protection civile ont travaillé main
dans la main ce n'est pas la première
fois d'ailleurs que vous travaillez
ensemble quels ont été les atouts de ce
travail en commun pour cette opération
de solidarité avec l'Ukraine
bonjour à toutes et tous au tout
simplement avec le Président l'isnard
nous voulions quelque chose de
pragmatique et d'efficace tout
simplement c'est à dire cette capacité à
être au plus près des collectivités
c'est un peu la force de la protection
civile au travers de notre maillage
territorial qui fait que dès le début on
a pu mettre en place cette chaîne ce
pont humanitaire ce premier kilomètre
dont parlait le président l'isnard ce
premier kilomètre qui est qui est très
important et qui est souvent le plus
compliqué celui de la collecte locale on
l'a mené tous ensemble et j'insiste sur
ce point c'est notre force elle est
collective c'est bien celle de du binôme
élu bénévole de protection civile qui a
permis de collecter et d'envoyer
l'ensemble ce matériel au plus vite dès
le 6ème jour de la collecte le premier
qu'on voit humanitaire partait en
direction de l'Ukraine et je retiendrai
quelques chiffres 8000 tonnes de
matériel chers élus 8000 tonnes de
matériel c'est 8000 tonnes c'est 15000
palettes qui ont été envoyées en un
temps record en moins de 5 mois sur
l'ensemble du territoire ukrainien c'est
24 Airbus c'est le poids de 24 Airbus
A380 qui ont pu être envoyés en un temps
record de façon ciblée et je rebondirai
sur les propos de Tibo Guignard
j'inspirais sur ce point c'est que
désormais on s'inscrit plus sur une on
est vraiment dans le cadre de la
reconstruction dans un premier temps sur
cette première tranche d'action on était
sur des produits de première nécessité
de secours déjà de reconstruction et
désormais on s'inscrit dans un travail
de reconstruction plus profond de
logistique et comme vous le disiez
désormais ce ne sont plus les dons en
nature qui sont nécessaires mais
vraiment le financement de groupe
logistique de moyenne chauffage j'en
parlais avec l'adjoint en mer de dodesa
tout à l'heure qui me disait une
nouvelle fois ce qu'il nous faut ce sont
des groupes électrogènes il nous faut
des stations de traitement de l'eau
il faut des stations de chauffage pour
que ces points de vie qui sont
constitués sur l'ensemble du territoire
ukrainien puisse être alimentés donc on
s'oriente de plus en plus sur cette
mission qui est celle de la logistique
du retour à la vie normale et puis comme
on le disait avec Monsieur l'Ambassadeur
il y a quelques jours voilà on espère
apporter notre expertise de protection
civile française en créant une sorte de
protection si ukrainienne pour que le
peuple
ukrainien puisse encore plus résilient
merci
et pour terminer cette séquence monsieur
le Président on retrouve en images le
message on retrouve tout de suite le
message du président de Linky qu'il a
sauté adresser au maire de France avant
d'Antony les hymnes de nos pays amis et
désormais frère voilà
en images Vladimir
en français
et j'invite à présent l'ensemble de
l'assistance des milliers de mères
présents dans cette pièce à ceux lever
j'ai envie de tout le monde à se lever
car nous allons en conclusion de cette
séquence de solidarité écouter les
hymnes de nos deux pays nous allons
écouter l'hymne ukrainien puis la
Marseillaise
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci
merci à tous
merci à nos amis ukrainiens
et nous allons maintenant et bien entrer
dans le débat d'orientation générale de
son sac sans 4e congrès des maires et
des présidents d'intercommunalité de
France
[Musique]
je vais les appeler
voilà c'est maintenant le temps du débat
d'orientation générale de ce sans 4e
congrès des mers et président
d'intercommunalité c'est le temps des
discours des échanges je rappelle que
vous pouvez intervenir poser des
questions témoigner de d'autres faire
part de vos propositions il y a un
espace question qui est de ce côté de la
salle pour votre expression ce congrès
et le vôtre et c'est bien d'ailleurs
l'esprit de ce débat d'orientation
générale et pour cette séquence nous
sommes toujours avec Muriel Fabre David
Lisnard qui ne doit pas être loin de la
scène qui nous rejoint qui fait son
retour nous a rejoint André Laignel le
premier vice-président délégué de la MF
et j'invite également à nous rejoindre
sur cette scène Guy Geoffroy qu'aux
président du comité législatif de l'AMF
maire de Combs-la-Ville en
Seine-et-Marne j'invite également
vraiment à nous rejoindre Philippe
Laurent deuxième vice-président de l'AMF
maire de Sceaux dans les Hauts-de-Seine
Joël balandro mère d'Evron secrétaire
général adjoint de l'AMF Catherine
Vautrin présidente du Grand Reims
vice-présidente de l'AMF Jacqueline bel
homme mère de Malakoff dans les
Hauts-de-Seine et Luc carbonas
co-président de la commission des
affaires sociales de la mfmer
d'Alfortville voilà prenez place
mesdames messieurs pour ce débat
d'orientation générale qui va commencer
avec les discours introductifs du
président et du premier vice-président
et nous invitons donc à retourner à la
tribune au pupitre David Lisnard
[Applaudissements]
nous reprenons avec enthousiasme en
train nos travaux après ce moment qui
était un moment je crois intense et fort
et puissant
puis bien évidemment très très heureux
que nous nous retrouvions ici
pour ce premier grand rendez-vous de la
MF après le renouvellement des instances
cette tribune que vous constatez c'est
la tribune d'une AMF soudée rassemblée
uni pour faire entendre la voix des
maires de France et des présidents
d'intercommunalité
pour travailler
comme nous l'avons toujours voulu et
comme la MF s'y attache depuis 1907
reconnu un terrain public depuis 1933
dans l'intérêt général
dans la loyauté à l'écart de l'exécutif
mais aussi dans la liberté et dans la
responsabilité de façon transparciane de
façon collégiale de façon unie
je remercie bien sûr tous les membres du
bureau du comité directeur tous ceux qui
s'impliquent à travers les commissions
les groupes de travail et qui font de
l'Association des maires de France en
partenariat avec les associations
départementales que je salue
chaleureusement aussi une réalité
vivante une réalité dynamique tonique
scène constructive
alors nous voici arrivés dans cette
première étape de nos notre assemblée
générale puisque les statues le
disposent et le devoir nous y conduit
nous devons mener cette discussion
d'activité sur l'activité de la MF
ce propos aussi qui est à propos
d'ouverture
et avec les parties plus statutaires qui
succéderont à l'intervention d'André les
Niel
toujours plus allant
et
malgré l'adversité parfois André qu'il
s'est affronté il l'a déjà démontré et à
travers et après le débat avec la salle
les débats ont commencé ont bien
commencé ils ont commencé d'ailleurs
hier avec cette journée des Outre-mer
qui je le crois et je parle sous le
contrôle de nos collègues ultramarins a
été une vraie réussite avec une
fréquentation peut-être encore je le
crois des témoignages très forts selon
le nouveau format que l'on essaie de
mettre en place avec beaucoup plus
d'interactions avec la salle et de
débats riches pas riche des moyens dont
nous disposons malheureusement mais
riche des idées qui étaient émises et
des constats sur le logement et sur la
sécurité et des témoignages
particulièrement poignants troublant
révélateur aussi de
forme d'impuissance publique régalienne
face à des problèmes de sécurité très
très violents Mayotte évidemment c'est
le président mais pardonnez-moi de pas
être exhaustif mais aussi on a évoqué la
Guyane les Antilles réunion et des
phénomènes qui renvoient de façon
paroxystique à ce que nous nous
constatons sur tout le territoire
français y compris sur le territoire
hexagonal avec
malheureusement des formes d'insécurité
d'un civisme de violence pas dans cette
forme
ultra telle qu'elle a été évoquée hier
mais qui sont non seulement dans nos
vies mais aussi désormais dans nos
campagnes
les débats ont commencé aussi ce matin
avec des tables rondes sur la transition
écologique qu'elle urgence qu'elle
nécessitait sur l'école sur la sécurité
sur la commande publique sur le cuivre
le réseau cuivre ainsi donc que d'autres
débats qui sont encore en cours
nous avons choisi avec l'équipe que j'ai
l'honneur de conduire de consacrer ce
congrès au terme du pouvoir agir
cette question pourrait ou cette
problématique pourrait paraître étrange
par définition le maire c'est celui qui
agit je dis souvent et je le répéterai
c'est parce que je trouve que cette
formule est assez juste que quelque soit
la taille de notre commune quelle que
soit sa typologie ces problématiques
nous sommes des praticiens du quotidien
mais cette question malheureusement elle
est elle n'a jamais été autant légitime
et elle doit nous interpeller puisque
jamais nous n'avons eu autant le devoir
d'agir si nous nous posons la question
du pouvoir agir c'est parce que il y a
un ardent de voix d'agir et que
parallèlement la capacité d'action elle
et ce n'est pas nouveau tant à se
réduire
tant à se réduire parce que
recentralisation parce que l'injonction
contradictoire alors ce devoir d'agir
quel est-il d'abord
c'est le devoir d'agir face à tous les
grands défis notre époque on utilise
souvent je crois attend le terme de
crise une crise par définition c'est un
état douloureux et provisoire quand les
choses s'éternissent et que c'est une
transition une transformation qu'il faut
savoir affronter maîtriser du mieux
possible alors bien sûr le défi de la
transition énergétique face aux défis
climatique comment lutter contre la part
entropique la par humaine du
réchauffement climatique nous y sommes
c'est une urgence c'est un défi c'est
aussi un moment de créativité
d'innovation de potentialité
le défi du numérique
le numérique conditionne grandement tous
les grands progrès qui vont accompagner
l'époque à venir le numérique est
incontournable et le risque est
proportionnel à l'opportunité comme
toujours dans la vie
le numérique doit être un outil
d'émancipation de progrès de sciences
d'optimisation mais pas un outil
d'aliénation de soumission et de
contrôle social comme certains régimes
l'exclus je pense à au régime chinois
par exemple des filles numériques nous y
sommes dans nos organisations communales
dans la régulation du trafic etc etc
le défi économique et social la création
de richesse l'art juste répartition de
la richesse thème qui n'échappe pas à
nos problématiques communales le défi
démographique celui du rapport au mode
de vie à l'identité problématique très
très difficile très chargée parfois
d'idéologie ou de présupposés le défi
sécurité
car l'ordre public et la condition
sinequanone de la liberté individuelle
et des libertés publiques
le défi de la qualité de vie parce que
c'est notre finalité c'est d'agir pour
la qualité de vie des habitants et c'est
une belle finalité c'est pas une
finalité mesquine
et ces défis nous les abordons dans un
contexte lui de crise
qui est une crise civique qui devrait
occuper toutes nos préoccupations toutes
nos pensées cette crise civique qui se
traduit par des taux d'abstention record
qui se traduit par des votes d'humeur ou
d'extrême qui se traduit par des
invictives dans le débat public très
souvent sans tension pleine de moralines
comme disait Nietzsche proportionnelle à
la vacuité du propos
crise civique qui est en fait une crise
profonde de notre démocratie donc de
notre liberté
alors face à tout cela bien oui nous
avons le devoir d'agir parce que nous
sommes des praticiens parce que nous
avons des solutions parce que de toute
façon nous n'avons pas le choix
nous agissons tous les jours nous
agissons dans l'urgence
sans nous comparer à ce qu'affrontent
nos collègues Ukrainiens mais lorsqu'il
y a des catastrophes naturelles lorsque
des incendies comme cet été ravages
certaines de nos communes lorsque les
crues éclairent lorsqu’un attentat
lorsqu'une pollution survient les Khmers
sont toujours les premiers les premiers
dans le temps et les premiers dans
l'espace au contact de la crise ils sont
toujours ceux qui sont identifiés par la
population et qui doivent des facto
coordonner les services cette notion de
risque majeur elle est essentielle elle
est une quasi je crois définition en
tout cas les consubstantielles à la
politique à la gestion de la cité c'est
pas simplement gérer les flux c'est
affronter la difficulté c'est protéger
le groupe est projeté le groupe c'est ça
la politique au sens noble et c'est
pourquoi
conformément aux engagements que nous
avions pris avec André avec toute
l'équipe nous avons mis en place un
groupe de travail
sur les risques majeurs qui a commencé
à travailler de précisons de travail de
façon très proactive vous verrez qu'en
2023 nous irons via très souvent les
associations départementales pour
proposer un mode opératoire pour aider
tous les maires de France et prise en
intercommunalité à aborder la
problématique des risques majeurs
nous devons prendre des décisions
difficiles parce que nous gérons des
légitimités contradictoires ah oui
le bistrot en bas de l'immeuble il a
raison de dire qu'il a besoin d'une
terrasse et d'animation parce que c'est
de l'emploi mais l'habitant au-dessus la
raison de dire qu'il veut dormir c'est à
nous de trancher ça c'est ce qui fait
l'intérêt de nos missions la
tranquillité les contradictions entre la
tranquillité l'activité économique entre
la liberté confessionnelle et les
communautarisme sujet particulièrement
difficile
notre action quotidienne c'est ce que
j'exprimais ce matin auprès de certains
journalistes c'est que elle est c'est
une fonction exécutive que celle de mer
et des luminal elle n'est pas dans les
grands effets d'annonce bien sûr qu'on
ne donne du sens à ce qu'on fait on
essaie de donner une dynamique mais elle
est dans l'exécution dans le détail
c'est le maire de la commune rurale du
Doubs qui ira déblayer un chemin enneigé
c'est le maire d'une grande ville plus
au centre qui devra prendre des
décisions de management auprès de
centaines d'agents
à chaque fois ce travail ne se voit pas
ce travail est passionnant ce travail
est un travail de patron de leaders de
gestionnaire de managers vous mettez le
terme que vous voulez tout simplement de
mandataire nous sommes mandatés et le
plus beau des mandats celui de la
proximité nous sommes des habitants
parmi les habitants mandatés par les
habitants nous vivons avec ce qui nous
mandatent nous ôtons mandatons aussi
puisque nous sommes citoyens
alors si notre devoir d'agir est une
évidence
il se heurte un nombre de blocages et
cette question se pose avons-nous le
pouvoir d'agir
et nous devons nous la poser
notre pouvoir d'agir est entravé mes
chers collègues
j'ai essayé au cours de cette année je
continuerai d'aller dans un maximum de
soi d'assemblées départementales soit de
rencontre avec des bureaux ou des
conseils d'administration j'ai rencontré
physiquement et je pense être en dessous
de la réalité au moins 5200 m en un an
est-ce que j'ai vu et bien sûr d'abord
une France magnifique notre pays est
merveilleux notre pays a un patrimoine
historique humain culturel sublime notre
pays est un eldorado mais j'ai vu aussi
quel que soit l'étiquette politique du
maire ou l'absence d'étiquette de
politique du maire quel que soit l'âge
le sexe etc et l'exaspération face à la
montée des contraintes face à deux
paramètres tout simple qui quoique on
démontre
au plan macro et bien au plan micro de
ce que nous vivons nous constatons et
ceux qui ont une expérience d'élus le
savent de plus en place d'entraves de
plus en plus entraves juridico
administratives et de moins en moins de
moyens financiers c'est une double
réalité qui met encore la capacité
d'action
perte de pouvoir financier alors André
leniel avec la précision et le sens de
la formule
à la fois bien réelle et légendaire
reviendra après moi sur ces
problématiques
je ne serai pas exhaustif et vous
épargnerez quelque part c'est une bonne
nouvelle pour chacun d'entre vous
inclusive de chacune mais revenir quand
même que sur quelques points
rappelez que nous ne sommes pas un
problème pour les finances publiques
qu'il y a un problème de finance
publique en France pas nouveau c'est pas
récent ça c'est pas amélioré ça c'est
même accentué mais que le problème des
finances publiques en France vient des
comptes sociaux et des contes de l'État
les collectivités territoriales et en
premier lieu les communes et les
intercommunalités respectent la règle
d'or nous ne le répéterons jamais assez
nous votons des budgets à l'équilibre
d'ailleurs ça n'a pas échappé à la MF à
la MF ça c'est sûr mais à la Cour des
comptes lapsus non révélateur
et nous pouvons dans la même semaine
nous voir reprocher d'être assis sur un
supposita d'or qui n'en est pas un qui
est juste une étape il épargne de
sagesse de précaution parce qu'il y a de
plus en plus de risques et d'ailleurs
donc au début obligé de pouvoir d'éparer
lorsqu'on le peut encore et puis
parallèlement de nous dire que nous
serions des fabricants de rond-points
considérés
cette rond-point tout phobie
mondaine
m'échappe alors certes il y a parfois
des décorations un peu kitsch sur nos
rond-point bon il faut qu'on l'admette
mais de façon très sérieuse vous n'avez
pas remarqué vous n'avez pas lu alors ça
vient de soit de populiste de gauche à
de populistes de droite y compris de
libéraux que je connais qui disent ah
c'est le maire qui font des ronds
écoutez d'abord on n'est pas des seuls
en fait il y a eu quatre fois moins de
morts sur les routes en 50 ans en France
avec plus de voitures je crois que
finalement les rampants ils sont pour
quelque chose mais au-delà de la boutade
comment résumer notre action à ça
comment pouvons-nous accepter de
continuer à être ainsi dénigré et puis
de dire qu'on gaspirait de l'argent mais
et puis d'un autre côté que on aurait su
terroriser
recroqueviller sur des trésors
municipaux la réalité est tout autre
et l'annonce
si les capacités le grand défi financier
qui est le nôtre c'est celui de
préserver des capacités
d'autofinancement parce que c'est de la
capacité d'autofinancement que dépendra
notre capacité à agir pour les
équipements pour la culture pour le
sport pour la justice sociale
pour les écoles pour les crèches pour la
lutte contre le réchauffement climatique
comment pouvons-nous imaginer que l'on
ne pouvait pas lutter contre climatique
si on ne peut pas isoler nos bâtiments
les 220 000 220000 km2
220 millions je reprends les 220
millions de kilomètres carrés
alors pourtant j'ai été très sobre à
midi on dirait du krazuki cher camarade
les deux
cent vingt mille mètres les 200 20
millions
dans un discours
en fait c'est ce chiffre est tellement
effrayant je n'ose pas le prononcer je
ne voulais pas casser l'ambiance et le
grand André Malraux disait qu'à mon
discours c'est celui où l'on apprend à
bégayer les 220 millions de mètres
carrés
deux bâtiments communaux et nous
l'évoquions hier soir avec Christophe
Béchu et qui ne délégation l'AMF
représente 80% des dépenses énergétiques
du bloc communal
donc lutter contre le réchauffement
climatique et pour préserver nos
capacités y compris d'investissement
c'est transformer des dépenses de
fonctionnement en ressources
d'investissement donc c'est arrivé à
investir pour isoler nos bâtiments alors
quand j'entends dire
que oui la dotation générale de
fonctionnement
augmente de 320 millions grâce notamment
à l'action l'AMF il faut quand même le
dire c'est 220 320 21730
moi je maintiens la position de la MF
qui est constante quelque soit le
président de la République qui n'est pas
une position polémique qui consiste à
dire les dotations ne sont pas un don
mais un du les dotations ne sont pas une
aide de l'État
les dotations et je le répéterai jeudi
je le répète à tous mes propos ne sont
pas une subvention de l'État le ministre
des comptes publics sur des médias
récemment disait jamais nous augmentons
la DGF de 330 millions c'est un effort
qui n'a jamais été réalisé depuis 13 ans
et
ne jamais l'État n'a autant aidé les
communes alors si l'aide de l'État c'est
la notation il faut annuler cette phrase
tout de suite les dotations ne sont pas
une aide il faut bien se souvenir la
dotation a été mise en place par là la
suppression de la patente puis ensuite
par les transferts de charges dans la
carte de la décentralisation donc
transfert de charges transfert de
ressources des grandes lois de faire
dont nous célébrons les 40 ans
et que l'engagement de l'État était de
dire nous transférons la charge nous
transférons la ressource qui sera
constante en franc et ensuite en euros
c'est-à-dire évidemment un excès à
l'inflation que jusqu'au début des
années 2000 sans discussion toutes les
dotations notamment la DGF était
réactualisé chaque année du montant de
l'inflation y compris dans les années 70
et début 80 quand la façon était bien
plus haute encore qu'aujourd'hui plus la
moitié de la croissance c'était une
règle et puis depuis les années 2000
c'était juste indexé puis en 2010
souvenez-vous la salle n'était pas
configuré la même façon j'étais dans
cette salle et dans la République de
l'époque après les subprimes avait dit
une indexons pas la notation bronca des
mères injuste titre puis 2014 2017
l'état pioche dans les notations puis
l'enveloppe est à nouveau fixée puis là
elle augmente de 330 sauf que
si on prend l'hypothèse d'inflation du
gouvernement pour 2023 c'est-à-dire sur
l'année correspondant à ces 330 millions
hypothèse assez optimiste de 4,2%
d'inflation on en rêverait frais ce
qu'en ce moment
les l'augmentation de la DGF pour le
bloc communal devrait être mécaniquement
de 800 millions d'euros
800 c'est plus gros que 330 donc
une augmentation de 330 mais je parle
sous le contrôle du président du Comité
des finances locales c'est je crois 1
74%. d'augmentation de la DGF donc c'est
nettement dessous de l'inflation si vous
aviez 1% d'inflation comme ce fut le cas
sur les dernières années et que c'était
figé et qu'on râle on râlé à l'époque
l'État en fait prélever 1% là en
augmentant 330 millions il oublie de
nous donner 500 millions donc le
prélèvement de l'État en 2023 sera
supérieur à ce qu'il était les années
précédentes sans augmentation en euros
courant de la DGF mais tout simplement
parce que la DGF n'augmente pas en neuro
constant on ne demande pas un effort à
l'état sur la dotation on demande juste
le prince le respect de la parole donnée
et que les dotations soient constantes
c'est-à-dire qu'elles soient réévaluée
en tenant compte de l'inflation c'est à
dire qu'elle soit contente en euros
constant voilà la problématique
financière dans laquelle nous sommes
alors
ça n'empêche pas cette remarque de dire
qu'il y a des discussions avancées dans
d'autres domaines et qu'il y a des
discussions même positives je les dis on
me reproche parfois mais moi je suis
honnête intellectuellement j'ai une
première ministre avec qui on arrive
pour l'instant à discuter avec respect
et de façon concrète et j'en dirais
quelques mots mais quand je dis à cette
question c'est pas moi qui la pose me
demande mais enfin vous n'avez jamais
été autant aidé donc je le rappelle que
c'est pas une aide et puis qu'on me dit
mais quand même
330 millions j'explique ce que je viens
d'expliquer et je dis c'est une esbroufe
communicationnelle c'est pas méchant
c'est un peu d'esbroufes un peu de la
poudre de perlimpinpin
développement et que une ministre ce
matin dit sur Public Sénat que j'ai vu
hier donc je leur parlerai quand je la
reverrai
dit c'est indécent le président l'isner
est indécent lorsqu'il parle de la DGF
je trouve que cet argument
communicationnel qui consiste à dire que
l'État c'est un peu nous tous l'état
nous fait un cadeau alors qu'il n'ajuste
pas la DGF à l'inflation vient je trouve
que cet argument communicationnel lui
est indécent et qu'il est provocateur au
moment où nous lançons nos travaux
et j'appelle
cette ministre
à la prudence à la à la au respect tout
simplement des positions qui sont les
nôtres et qui ne sont pas belliqueuses
qui sont des positions d'arguments qui
étaient partagées encore il y a quelques
semaines d'ailleurs
par la même ministre lorsqu'elle était
encore mère
quand le ministre de l'Économie fustige
les communes qui seraient mal gérées
parce qu'elle recruteraient je dis
devons-nous refuser de recruter les aesh
qui sont désormais de notre
responsabilité sur le temps périscolaire
et notamment de la pause méridienne pour
accueillir inclure pour reprendre la
terminologie de l'époque les enfants
handicapés bien sûr que nous honorons
d'essayer de recruter des aesh pour que
les enfants porteurs de handicap est
accès à l'école
devons-nous recruter refuser de recruter
des policiers municipaux quand dans la
réalité des zones polices malgré le
travail méritant courageux de la police
nationale les primo intervenants des
facto sont des policiers municipaux je
ne crois pas que nous gérons mal lorsque
nous renforçons nos police municipales
bref devons-nous être jugés parce que le
plus important c'est cela y a-t-il une
entité qui s'appelle l'État qui serait
en mesure de nous donner des brevets de
bonnes ou mauvaise gestion là où la
gestion communale ne relève que de la
libre administration communale relève du
contrat social local et non pas
d'un État dont la qualité de gestion la
maîtrise des déficits la maîtrise de la
masse salariale ne nous a pas jusqu'à
maintenant éclabousser par la pertinence
alors toutes ces positions
qui ont vu depuis 2010 en euros constant
l'état prélevé 46 milliards d'euros sur
les finances des communes et
parallèlement augmenter son propre
déficit
commune et intercommunalités qui ne sont
pas un problème non plus pour la dette
puisque nous respectons la règle d'or
que nous l'empruntons que pour
l'investissement là où il y a un actif
là où l'État lui empreinte pour son
fonctionnement pour céder ce qui est
prohibé pour nous la juste titre là où
les dépenses la dette des collectivités
représentait il y a 25 ans 25% de la
dette publique c'est assez facile comme
chiffre aujourd'hui nous sommes à 9 % le
bloc communal représente 4,5% du total
de la dette publique et c'est 4,5% ne
sont liés qu'à des actifs c'est-à-dire
qu'il y a de l'investissement donc quel
que soit la qualité de gestion d'une
commune peut se discuter d'un point de
vue macroéconomique nous sommes une
ressource
nous sommes un apport nous sommes une
solution nous améliorons la présentation
des comptes publics à Bruxelles et c'est
pourquoi nous sommes aussi très
vigilants sur l'encadrement des défenses
publiques donc ces positions là les MF
les défendent parce que défendent ces
positions c'est défendre le pouvoir
d'agir des mères ce qui nous empêche pas
de dialoguer avec le gouvernement et je
le dis avec autant de force je ne sais
pas c'est à vous de juger mais en tout
cas avec autant d'honnêteté que la
relation avec l'actuel gouvernement
morne est une relation respectueuse est
une relation de dialogue sauf vous
l'avez compris quelques exceptions et
unique roche
que
nos discussions nous ont permis d'avoir
des avancées je pense par exemple à un
sujet qui qui revient souvent qui est
celui de l'actualisation des valeurs
locatives des biens commerciaux et
industriels avec une réforme des saveurs
locatives qui avaient le paradoxe de
pénaliser les commerces de proximité les
mêmes qu'on doit aider dans le cœur de
ville
le gouvernement a entendu nos arguments
et la prononcer une sorte de moratoire
de report de cette nouvelle approche et
nous allons travailler sur les critères
avec Bercy en tout cas c'est ce que
propose les MF qui est une force de
solution puisque c'est le Congrès des
solutions ici et c'est ce que nous
mettrons en exergue
le filet de sécurité sur l'énergie
c'est pas le mécanisme le plus simple à
comprendre mais dans les dispositions de
la Loire effectivement significative
2022 si notre capacité
d'autofinancement baisse de 25%.
beaucoup
quel ne représente plus que moins de 20%
des recettes de fonctionnement que ces
recettes de fonctionnement
elles-mêmes
sont dans une commune dont le potentiel
de richesse est inférieur au double de
la moyenne de la commune de la strate et
donc il y a eu un critère qui a été
ajouté l'augmentation de la facture
énergétique représente au moins 60% de
l'augmentation des dépenses de
fonctionnement je vous remercie de vous
applaudissements parce que j'ai beaucoup
travaillé de créer
et bien vous pouvez être éligible à
dispositif d'aide dans la réalité comme
nous le pressentions les nombres de
communes éligibles et beaucoup plus
faibles que les effets d'annonce qu'il y
avait prononcé nous avons ellef a été
l'association je dis là la seule à
défendre
n'est-ce pas André le principe
d'universalité du dispositif de
protection des communes face à cette
crise
très très puissante qui nous entêtent
nous obsède nous préoccupe dans la
réalisation de nos budgets communaux de
l'augmentation des factures énergétiques
avec des cas particulièrement douloureux
et difficiles dans beaucoup de communes
pas simplement les petites communes il y
a pas de petits maires mais il y a des
petites communes mais aussi toutes les
communes qui assument des charges de
centralité et qui ont des coûts
énergétiques par habitant qui sont
au-dessus de la moyenne de l'ensemble
des communes
et à ce titre le dispositif dans
l'esprit tel qu'il a été annoncé par
Isabelle borne est bon nous sommes en
pleine négociation avec Matignon et la
creux qui est la Commission de
régulation d'énergie pour que le prix de
référence du kilowatt-heure qui est à
325 euros soit ABC parce que comme on
dit chez certains maires les dispositifs
ça dispositif universel sur lequel le
gouvernement a prévu deux milliards plus
de milliards donc il y a un effort réel
mais qui en fait passerait par la prise
en compte de l'augmentation de la
facture énergétique à hauteur de 50% au
dessus d'un prix 325 euros du
kilowattheure sauf que quand on passe
comme beaucoup de mer en témoignent je
sais pas de 540 100 à 300 on est face à
une solution inextricable et on est en
deçà du seuil donc au moment où je vous
parle mais je ne me refuse à tout procès
d'attention et je je crois profondément
à la bonne volonté de l'exécutif en la
matière
le filet de sécurité n'ont pas fait de
sécurité mais le l'amortisseur
d'électricité pour les communes de
bénéficiant pas du tarif réglementé
l'énergie est en cours de finalisation
des laboration et l'AMF est un
partenaire proactif pour défendre la
voix légitime des communes et
intercommunalités de France profondément
impacté par ses évolutions sur le fond
vert sur le fond vert nous saluons
l'esprit du fond à l'esprit de ceux qui
proposent le font Christophe BECHU nous
a rappelé encore ce matin hier que des
grandes aspirations de la MF étaient
prises en compte dans la conception du
fond il est évalué à 2 milliards
auxquels il faut retrancher 300 millions
de prolongement du fond free donc 1
million 7 milliard 700 millions et je
sais que André reviendra là dessus tout
à l'heure sur la réalité des chiffres
prévus par Bercy pour faire face à ce
fond je le laisse les faits de de
l'annonce de la réalité de ces chiffres
ceci le principe positif c'est que
nous nous demandions
à ce qu'il n'y ait plus
d'affectation des fonds d'État sous
forme d'appels à projet ou d'appel à
manifestation d'intérêt parce que ces
appels à projets ces manifestations
d'intérêt ou produit dérivés écartent
toutes les communes et communautés de
communes qui n'ont pas d'ingénierie
juridico administrative les délais sont
très souvent courts et amplifient
amplifient la fracture territoriale et
le principe qui a été retenu est très
simple on verra sous quelle forme les
préfets des attributs ronds c'est que
ces fonds seront attribués donc sur la
pertinence du projet pour décarboner ou
améliorer la relation de l'équipement
avec l'écosystème par le porteur de
projet par le maître d'ouvrage donc la
commune de l'intercommunalité ça c'est
positif
nous avons
enfin
exprimé nos réticences à l'égard de
toutes ces tutelles juridico
administratives qui auraient des
annonces des chocs de simplification
je commence à avoir un certain âge à
chaque fois que j'entends un gouvernant
qui soit de gauche de droite ou en même
temps c'est pas la question dire il y a
un choc de quelque chose à la fin ça se
traduit en flop du truc j'ai entendu il
y a 5 ans un choc de la mise des
logements et jamais aussi peu de mise en
chantier de logement le choc de
compétitivité on fait un record de
déficit du commerce extérieur le choc de
simplification on n'a jamais autant eu
de procédure en disant 73% d'articles de
loi au réglementaires de plus s'applique
sur les communes de France 73%
d'augmentation du nombre mes chers
collègues et amis de textes de
réglementaire et législatif qui nous
concerne on le sait bien nous sommes
face à un défi bureaucratique c'est pas
Frédéric Masquelier mon collègue de
Saint-Raphaël qui sort un ouvrage
sur l'enfer il a apporté son fan club
ils sont pas très très nombreux non plus
mais ah si quand même qui me démentira
mais sans être exhaustif en la matière
on l'a bien vu sur le zan l'enfer est
pavé de bonnes intentions comme
l'écrivait Dante et bien sûr qu'il faut
lutter contre l'artificialisation des
sols on l'a évoqué à toutes nos
assemblées toutes nos réunions je vais
pas être exhaustive là-dessus mais on
voit bien que la façon verticale
monolithique de mettre des objectifs qui
ensuite n'ont pas de traduction possible
localement
vont rendre obligatoire tellement de
modifications législatives que comme sur
la loi Serru ce sera un maquis
bureaucratique de dérogation potentielle
qui créeront des ruptures d'égalité là
où la loi se voulait trop égalitaire on
l'a bien vu là aussi hier soir ce qui
n'est-ce pas Philippe on nous parlions
avec le ministre qui était d'accord avec
nous sur le fait de dire ah oui mais on
prévoit vous avez raison il faut qu'on
prévoit un dispositif et de bonne foi et
de bonne volonté d'ailleurs pour les
communes rurales et puis à notre
dispositif à la fin c'est un détricotage
de la loi avant qu'elle soit prononcée
qu'elle soit exécutoire nous rendons
quand même dans l'obligation de
d'attaquer au Conseil d'État les décrets
d'applications pris un petit peu à la
sauvette en avril dernier dans un
contexte politique qui était pas le plus
j'allais dire propice à un débat serein
décret d'application sur le zan qui à la
fois sur la nomenclature et sur
l'inscription dans les documents qui le
rendront posables en droit dans les
stradettes et non pas dans les documents
d'objectifs sont pour nous incompatibles
avec l'esprit de la loi je ne sais pas
si l'affaire est encore enrôlé au
Conseil d'État mais je crois que les
arguments juridiques de la MF sont les
bons et ils vise à permettre d'avoir un
zéro objectif artificialisation nette
qui ne soit pas contradictoire avec les
légitimes aspirations à l'équipement et
au développement des communes et
notamment des communes rurales
ruralité
[Applaudissements]
que nous avons
mis en exergue vous savez la ruralité on
entend toujours parler avant les
échéances et puis après tout le monde
oublie mais nous on a voulu créer un
groupe de travail spécifique pour
notamment nous interroger sur le
dispositif des adrr avec un rendu récent
grâce à l'origine Poveda et à Ludovic
Rochette et on était avec Ludovic pour
présenter ses travaux et donc l'AMF je
crois est sur le point d'obtenir une
actualisation une prolongation une
pérennité d'un dispositif qui devait
s'arrêter qui nous paraît pertinent à
condition de le mettre à l'échelle de la
commune qui est celui des edrr donc nous
continuons de plaider pour le
renforcement et la modernisation des LRR
de même au cours de ces derniers mois
nous avons créé un groupe de travail sur
les relations transfrontalières
de même nous avons créé une délégation
AMF aux outre-mer qui tout de suite a
été reconnu dans sa légitimité reçue par
le Président de la République reçu par
le ministre des Outre-mer qui hier nous
a adressé un discours très intéressant
et je crois très porteur d'espoir sur
une possibilité de travail au profit des
Outre-mer entre l'État et l'AMF et les
collectivités et communes d'outre-mer
de même nous avons et nous allons
continuer renforcer le lien avec notre
réseau de 102 associations
départementales n'est-ce pas Joël je
crois que c'est un point très important
nous associations départementales sont
une richesse nous étions engagés
d'ailleurs Philippe Laurent comme moi
l'année dernière dans nos programmes à
renforcer ce réseau nous avons non
seulement mis en place nous essayons
d'être présent systématiquement dans les
assemblées on peut pas tout le temps
mais on essaie j'ai bien noté y compris
en Normandie mon cher ami et mais aussi
d'organiser d'un séminaire où on réunit
les directeurs les dad les pad d'avoir
des objectifs communs et je pense que
c'est une grande richesse pour faciliter
l'information pour faciliter l'échange
d'expérience de terrain et dans le
combat que nous allons mener au cours
des prochains mois notamment de
propositions de lutte contre la
bureaucratie puisque c'est la
bureaucratie qui entrave notre pouvoir
d'agir je demanderai vraiment aux
associations départementales de nous
faire remonter tous les exemples
d'injonction contradictoire que nous
recevons de d'absurdité administrative
pour pouvoir les
identifier les dénoncer et ensuite faire
des propositions de simplification
juridico administrative bref sur tous
ces défis sur toutes ces exigences sur
toutes ces difficultés je ne suis pas
exhaustif on pourrait parler des déserts
médicaux de nos discussions avec La
Poste pour la négociation du contrat de
présence postale à chaque fois
l'AMF est au service des communes de
France et des intercommunalités de
France pour défendre leur pouvoir d'agir
défendre le pouvoir d'agir c'est
défendre tout simplement
la réalité
du civisme en France c'est défendre une
certaine idée de la démocratie on
demande on ne l'Association des maires
de France n'est pas un syndicat de
défense des mers c'est tout simplement
l'association légitime et représentative
des habitants qui veulent une démocratie
communale vivante parce que la
République ne peut se passer
de commune de comme une vivante de
communes qui s'adapte de communes qui se
modernise de communes qui font la
transmission entre le passé le présent
et l'avenir et c'est pourquoi
l'association des maires de France plus
que jamais fidèle à sa raison d'être à
sa promesse à sa vocation de défense des
libertés locales de promotion des
libertés locales
sera toujours là pour aiguillonner
l'exécutif vers véritablement un nouvel
acte de décentralisation plus dans la
République
prenons le contre-pied de ce qui avait
été dit il y a un homme ici même il y a
un an
en commentant la résolution qui avait lu
André leniel
a tenu un propos le 10 octobre dans la
Mayenne très favorable à la
décentralisation reprenant les termes
même de la MF
il faut que nous l'encouragions
ce sont les termes qui nous avaient été
donnés le 5 septembre dans la Réunion
qui tendait à mobiliser son élus pour
réussir le lancement du Conseil national
de la refondation
nous disons que nous nous voulons être
responsables nous voulons rendre des
comptes
si nous voulons être responsable et
rendre compte nous voulons rendre des
comptes à tous les sens du terme nous
voulons un lien fiscal avec les
habitants parce que c'est ça la
responsabilité
nous voulons un pouvoir d'action
financier nous pouvons nous voulons un
pouvoir d'action juridique nous ne
voulons plus voir nous pouvoir
d'urbanisme entraver par les schémas
directeurs qui s'entrechoquent par les
codes par les directives
par cette contradiction d'injonction
bureaucratique qui nous entravent et
nous pénalise au quotidien parce que ce
nous dont je parle c'est pas nous-mêmes
c'est nous citoyens c'est nous habitons
habitants de France parce que nous
savons que le renouveau de la France que
la refondation de la France pour prendre
le terme du CNR que l'espérance d'une
France
moderne ouverte fidèle à ses racines et
conquérante dans le 21e siècle ne pourra
se faire qu'avec des communes fortes
libres et responsables vive les communes
de France
voilà la parole est maintenant à André
Deniel 1er vice-président de
l'Association des maires de France
alors
c'est à VOUS André Lenel
et nous vous écoutons
merci
merci David de tes mots amicaux et tes
encouragements
c'est vrai qu'il y a eu ces derniers
jours de grands blessés du sport
Benzema
les manifestement on m'a oublié
[Applaudissements]
je voudrais vous dire tout le plaisir
qui est le mien de vous retrouver je
vais dire un plaisir encore plus grand
tout simplement parce qu'il y a quelques
jours je ne savais pas
si je pourrais être là ce moment
il me retrouver devant vous avec vous
lors de ce congrès
c'est évidemment pour moi un immense
bonheur
le bonheur des retrouvailles le bonheur
des débats le bonheur des contradictions
le bonheur des propositions mais c'est
tous ensemble que nous savons l'assumer
je suis heureux de vous retrouver même
si
j'ai quand même des contacts même avec
une béquille
je constate que beaucoup d'entre vous
sont arrivés ici avec plus d'anxiété que
d'espoir
c'est le résultat de 5 années de crise
et d'aggravation de la situation de nos
communes et intercommunalités mais c'est
aussi l'aggravation de la situation des
habitants de chacune de nos communes et
nous le constatons chaque jour pour
beaucoup d'entre eux la fin du mois
n'est plus le 25
mais le 18 le 15
nous voyons dans nos sortes municipaux
d'actions sociales n'est-ce pas Luc
monter les demandes de la part de nos
concitoyens
cette situation de crise multiple que
nous avons nous mère de France à agir à
pouvoir agir
il y a eu les gilets jaunes les crises
sanitaires économiques sociales
environnementales si vite et maintenant
international et bien entendu avec pour
conséquence parmi beaucoup d'autres
l'inflation qui taraude chacun d'entre
nous au moment où nous sommes censés
préparer nos budgets
les mères comme j'allais dire toujours
son propre première ligne
il faut face par l'État a souvent été
absent souvenez-vous des débuts de la
crise sanitaire
quand il a été imprévoyant hésitant et
il lui arrive encore aujourd'hui de
l'être
et quand il est malheureusement donneur
de leçons
nous considérons au mieux comme des
supplétifs
et au pire comme des incompétents
rappelez-vous nous étions trop nombreux
incompétents et il fallait donc réduire
le nombre de maires d'élus locaux et
probablement sans doute en
arrière-pensée de nos communes nous n'en
sommes plus là heureusement dans le
discours
mais dans les faits quotidiens ça n'est
pas si simple
nous avons collectivement tous ensemble
pendant ces 5 années dernière pour
certains c'est un peu moins puisqu'ils
sont de nouveau mais parmi nous mais
nous avons tous fait face nous avons
tous fait face durant toute cette
période en apportant la preuve de notre
réactivité de notre initiative de nos
compétences et démontrant ainsi que la
commune ces équipes de fonctionnaires
territoriaux l'ensemble de ces élus
reste
l'incarnation de la proximité cette
valeur qui est de plus en plus
importante pour nos concitoyens qui se
sentent tellement isolés dans leur
quotidienneté dans leurs problèmes mais
ça conduit ce que nous soyons aussi
souvent et c'est une lourde tâche à la
fois le premier recours des habitants de
nos communes mais aussi
parfois aussi le dernier espoir
et c'est lourd pour chacun d'entre nous
de se sentir cette responsabilité alors
que nous avons le sentiment que le
pouvoir d'agir
n'est plus dans nos possibilités ne nous
permet plus de faire face de répondre
aux problématiques aux misères auxquels
nous sommes confrontés
au moment où nous sommes réunis en ce
moment même
je veux le dire mais vraiment sans
esprit polémique
en ce moment même nous arrivons aux
limites de l'exercice du pouvoir agir
nos moyens d'action
se dégradent genre parlerai bien entendu
et pouvoir agir pour juguler la
dégradation accélérée de nos services
publics et le recours des moyens de nos
communes pour y faire face ça s'appelle
recentralisation
tutelle étouffement financier avec un
gouvernement qu'il y a encore seulement
quelques semaines
décrivait les communes comme
financièrement à l'aise
avec un standard je rappelle
l'expression tu l'as évoqué aussi David
sur lequel nous sommes censés être assis
je vous en supplie mes chers collègues
si un seul parmi vous est assis sur un
tas d'or je lui demande de lever la main
et de nous dire comment il fait
je n'en vois pas
et même la Cour des comptes d'ailleurs
qui tenait le même langage sur notre
aisance supposée reconnaît aujourd'hui
que la situation est que c'est un mot
faible mais pour la Cour des comptes
c'est un mot fort que notre situation
est préoccupante
je les recevais devant le Comité des
finances locales la semaine dernière
je ne dirais pas que j'ai bu du petit
lait parce que ça aurait été un lamer
mais les entendre enfin reconnaître que
la situation financière de nos
collectivités est une préoccupation ça
fait quand même chaud au cœur après
avoir entendu pendant tant et tant de
moi exactement le contraire
cette préoccupation elle concerne aussi
bien les services publics nationaux que
nos services publics locaux je ne
citerai que deux services publics
nationaux
qui sont sans doute les plus importants
pour la nation je mets à part les
pouvoirs régaliens bien entendu
c'est l'éducation et la santé
l'éducation moi je sais pas comment
c'est dans vos départements mais dans le
mien on n'a jamais connu autant de
classe
qui soit sans titulaire
on n'a jamais connu autant de
spécialités qui soient sans enseignants
et l'on n'a jamais connu une période où
il y a aussi peu de candidats au
concours de l'éducation nationale
l'éducation nationale mes chers
collègues est en train de se déliter en
profondeur
en profondeur
et bien entendu c'est l'avenir même
de notre nation qui est en cause
quand son éducation publique n'est plus
en capacité de répondre aux besoins
élémentaires des générations qui sont
les nôtres
[Applaudissements]
en même temps la crise de recrutement
des enseignants on peut la comprendre
comparer les anciens les salaires des
enseignants en France avec les salaires
des enseignants des pays voisins
c'est parfois moitié parfois 50% de
moins
nos enseignants sont parmi les pays
développés les moins prises en
considération dans le cadre de leur
carrière
c'est un contresens absolu quand on se
préoccupe de l'avenir du pays tout
entier et la santé
le public
qui s'assèche
j'allais dire à la fois financièrement
mais ça ça a commencé depuis longtemps
et qui perd peu à peu ses praticiens
ces personnels infirmiers
bref toutes les spécialités à tel point
que maintenant partout en France on a la
menace de fermeture de service
chez quelques déplacements moi aussi en
province et dans quelques-uns mes
déplacements j'ai constaté que c'était
le service de pédiatrie qui était en
danger et je connais même plusieurs
exemples dont mes voisins de Bourges qui
craignaient de perdre leur service de
pédiatrie mais si même on en est à ce
que nos enfants ne puissent plus être
prises en charge correctement sur le
plan sanitaire ou allons-nous
moi j'ai la menace dans ma ville dans
mon centre hospitaliers
qu'à partir des jours à venir je n'ai
plus d'urgence la nuit
on dit mais que voulez-vous qu'on y
fasse on ne trouve plus de personnes
mais je vais faire la même remarque que
pour les enseignants
quelle considération quelles conditions
de travail sont offerts à ceux qui
travaillent dans nos centres
hospitaliers
surtout j'allais dire au milieu de
l'échelle ou en bas comment voulez-vous
être attractif
oui il y a des crises de vocation mais
ce ne sont pas des crises de vocation
spontanées ce sont des crises de
vocation qui sont créées par les
conditions de travail et de salaire
qu'on fait à ces salariés et ça ça n'est
pas acceptable parce que ça casse en
profondeur un service public de service
public je pourrais continuer la liste
qui sont fondamentaux pour l'avenir de
notre pays
[Musique]
préoccupante aussi
la situation par
vous vous en doutez la dégradation des
moyens de nos communes et
intercommunalités
on va encore m'accuser
d'être polémique mais je vais argumenter
en 50 crise
50 crise parce que ça quasiment été
inattu en plus il vous démarrez depuis
les gilets jaunes puis si c'est 4 ans et
demi vous me pardonnerez
on a le sentiment
que certains n'ont rien appris
c'est vrai David le ton a changé
nous n'en sommes plus aux invectives
on ne nous ressort plus balance ton
maire
mais si le temps a changé
le fond lui est resté le même vous en
voulez quelques exemples
le précédent
il a commencé par la suppression de la
taxe d'habitation
je vais pas revenir sur ces conséquences
sa mécanique et ce nouveau quinquennat
il démarre avec la volonté de supprimer
la TVA
c'est quand même extraordinaire
que l'État chaque fois qu'il souhaite
faire un cadeau fiscal ne le fasse pas
avec ses propres impôts mais avec les
impôts locaux nous mettons ainsi en
tutelle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les contrats de Cahors étaient au début
du précédent mandat
et nous avons maintenant les contrats de
confiance
vous n'arrive pas à comprendre comment
on peut appeler ça un contrat de
confiance
alors que ce n'est qu'un contrat de
Cahors qui n'a plus lieu à Cahors qui
n'est plus signé mais qui est une
aggravation par rapport au contrat de
Cahors comprennent qui pourra
j'ai beaucoup travaillé pour arriver à
vous dire ça
mais la réalité
c'est que c'est un acte de méfiance
fondamental comment peut-on parler de
contrat de confiance alors que l'on
pointe du doigt chacune de nos communes
chacune de nos collectivités
territoriales en disant comme on est pas
sûr de vous on va vous mettre des
limites
aux dépenses que vous pouvez effectuer
soi-disant dans le cadre de la libre
administration de nos collectivités
territoriales oui c'est un acte de
méfiance fondamental
inacceptable
et donc la question n'est pas de savoir
si c'est nouveau pseudo contrat auront
des sanctions ou pas parce qu'on nous
dit Oh peut-être qu'on pourrait voir au
cas par cas qui n'irait pas
systématiquement des sanctions non c'est
pas ça la question la question c'est que
nous n'acceptons pas cette tutelle
supplémentaire tu ne m'acceptons pas que
l'on nous désigne auprès de nos
concitoyens comme de mauvais
gestionnaires qui devraient être
par un État qui lui serait vertueux nous
savons bien que ça n'est pas la vérité
et que c'est plutôt l'inverse que nous
vivons les uns et les autres
[Musique]
la recentralisation était au cœur du
quinquennat précédent ça continue
le zan
il y avait le pont aux âne je sais pas
si c'est de mettre nature mais là nous
ne manquons pas de zan
c'est une mécanique infernale qui
risquerait de mettre beaucoup de nos
territoires dans l'incapacité de se
développer et c'est bien entendu
totalement inacceptable mais c'est
pourquoi un accord nous avons décidé
c'est un fait rarissime d'attaquer des
décrets devant le Conseil d'État
[Musique]
et puis il paraît que la bonne nouvelle
du quinquennat nouveau c'est le cercle
vous savez contrat de relance et de
transition énergétique ou écologique je
ne sais plus très bien
moi là aussi je vais vous lancer un
appel
signer mon CRTO j'étais parti le dernier
en France
parce que je cherchais le bien-fondé du
dispositif et puis bon
je vais pas continuer à faire ma
mauvaise tête donc nous avons décidé de
signer
et depuis je suis comme Monsieur de
Soubise sa lanterne à la main
cherchant dans les sous-sols j'ai pas
encore réussi à pénétrer ce Bercy où
serait les crédits qui seraient
consacrés au CRPE
si vous les avez trouvés merci de me le
dire
mais en réalité c'est un processus de
recentralisation c'est un processus qui
est de fléchage de l'ensemble de nos
dépenses en fonction des priorités de
l'État et non pas en fonction des
besoins de nos concitoyens car ils ne
sont pas toujours semblables ou demande
de l'État
alors
j'en viens à l'actualité chaude si j'ose
dire c'est à dire la loi de finances
c'est en plein débat au Parlement et
donc je ne veux pas moi faire un jour au
Parlement de ce qui pourrait sortir des
débats enfin si par hasard on sort du
49-3
alors que dit cette loi mais elle
renforce la recentralisation d'abord à
La Grave la nationalisation de l'impôt
en le remplaçant par des ressources qui
sont à la seule main de l'État puisque
la CVAE serait remplacé d'ailleurs on ne
sait pas exactement où aujourd'hui
comment par quoi et dans quelle limite
mais bon et alors la fiscalité
aujourd'hui ressemble de plus en plus à
un jeu de Mikado
on retire un impôt ici au risque que
tous s'effondre mais sans aucune
profondeur de vue on l'a constaté avec
la taxe d'habitation aujourd'hui
plusieurs années après la suppression
nous ne savons toujours pas comment nous
pouvons modifier les critères qui
permettent la répartition de l'ensemble
des dotations à l'ensemble des communes
parce que ça n'avait en aucun cas été
anticipé par le gouvernement qui a
décidé de la suppression de la taxe
d'habitation et bien nous sommes dans le
même cas aujourd'hui avec la suppression
de la CVA
nous avons présenté au gouvernement
90 questions principales pour cette loi
de finances il y avait beaucoup d'autres
mais je ne vais énoncer que les quatre
principales j'ai eu la charge avec
des amis ici présents de rencontrer à
deux reprises et ça fait plutôt presque
3h d'entretien on a été écouté
malheureusement le constat est amer
d'abord l'indexation de la DGF
ça a été évoqué par David je ne vais pas
faire beaucoup plus loin j'aurais juste
un petit point non pas de désaccord mais
de mode de calcul David moi je calcule
pas sur l'inflation à venir
je calcule sur l'inflation de 2022
parce que nous n'avons eu aucune
compensation pour l'instant en 2022
alors que nous allons être probablement
à 7 et demi peut-être 8% d'inflation
pour ce qui concerne le bloc communal
est-ce qu'on va mettre ça dans notre
poche décider qu'on aura perdu à tout
jamais c'est 7 et demi à 8% d'inflation
c'est-à-dire en réalité des moyens
essentiels pour la vie de nos
collectivités donc la demande c'est
l'indexation de la DGS sur le chiffre de
l'inflation de 2022 pour remettre les
contrats à jeu les compteurs à jour
et vous imaginez bien que cette ennemi
alors ce sera cette deux comme pardonne
mes excès mais
cette 2 et on nous a loue
1 74% pour être précis d'augmentation de
la DGF et on nous dit et c'est vrai
c'est sans précédent depuis 10 ans
bah oui
mais les dix années qui viennent de
s'écouler c'était en gros 1% d'inflation
parfois moins et donc les cinq dernières
années on a perdu en gros 1% par an
puisque c'était la stabilité en euros
courant et non pas en Europe constant
mais cette année
cette année
c'est pas 1% d'inflation auquel nous
sommes confrontés
nous allons forcément si on en reste là
perdre 5,3% de pouvoir d'achat de
pouvoir d'action pour chacune de nos
communes si ça ne s'appelle pas un
assèchement des finances locales alors
je ne sais pas c'est le ce que le mot
assèchement veut dire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la suppression de la cedeae c'était
notre deuxième revendication donc vous
l'avez compris la première c'était
l'indexation de la DGF qui reste notre
revendication aujourd'hui
sur la CVE notre position c'est le
retrait de la suppression j'ai appris
avec bonheur que ça avait été voté par
le Sénat
donc merci Auda d'avoir voté la
suppression de la suppression
malheureusement je ne suis pas sûr que
ça aille jusqu'au terme de la navette
parlementaire
et être contre la suppression du CVAE là
aussi c'est simplement parce qu'après
avoir coupé le lien entre nos communes
et le citoyens supprimant la taxe
d'habitation
aujourd'hui on va supprimer un lien
essentiel entre nos communes et le monde
économique
et que surtout c'est une fois de plus ce
serait j'espère que ça n'arrivera pas
une fois de plus une nationalisation de
l'impôt qui bien entendu sera compensée
par l'État librement dans la durée et
sans que nous ayons la capacité à faire
évoluer les choses
et puis le redressement des comptes
publics
quel extraordinaire aventure
quelle extraordinaire aventure donc
d'abord pourquoi nous mettre les
communes en maison de redressement
est-ce que nous avons gravementé
nous n'avons pas de déficit la masse de
nos emprunts est inférieurs de notre
dette est inférieure à 9%. et en plus
nous payons nous-mêmes nous payons nos
intérêts nous remboursons le capital
nous ne pesons en rien sur les finances
de l'État
et
comment pouvons-nous accepter que se
redressement viennent ainsi nous frapper
là aussi disons ah faut qu'il participe
comme si nous n'avions pas participé
déjà depuis des années et des années
on nous a ponctionné sur les dix années
qui viennent de s'écouler 46 milliards
est-ce que cette ponction de 46
milliards à améliorer ne serait-ce
qu'une seule des dix années le solde de
l'État
je vais pas vous demander de chercher
j'ai cherché pour vous ça n'est jamais
arrivé
on nous a ponctionné mais ça n'a jamais
amélioré les finances de l'État
et puis l'énergie alors j'ai bien
entendu David
avec quelle science tu nous as décrit ce
que serait comment l'amortisseur on a eu
des boucliers on a eu des filets là ce
serait l'amortisseur
elle doit être amortie parce que je
comprends rien
quand je t'ai entendu je me suis dit il
va nous dire à la fin l'ange du
capitaine ah non il paraît que tu nous
expliquais ce qu'éventuellement nous
pourrions toucher pour venir compenser
nos dépenses alors aussi faisons ça il
faut que la compensation elle soit
universelle faut pas qu'il y ait des
critères attirent la Rigot qui
d'ailleurs parfois sont contradictoire
entre eux il faut simplement que nous
puissions bénéficier du tarif réglementé
comme cela et le cas pour nos
concitoyens pour certaines de nos
entreprises et contrairement à ce qu'on
dit pas pour toutes les petites communes
mais pour un certain nombre d'entre
elles donc notre demande elle est claire
c'est l'accès pour tous au tarif
réglementé voilà les quatre conditions
alors j'entends bien le discours
d'ailleurs même si je voulais pas le
l'entendre il est tellement répété par
le gouvernement on nous dit
beaucoup d'efforts sont faits
on nous annonce des milliards à foison
pour le futur
c'était de 1 milliard de près alors on
mélange parfois les subventions les
prêts bref
moi j'ai une suggestion à vous faire je
pourrais peut-être vous la faire voter à
main levée
si vraiment ça déclenche autant de
milliards chaque fois qu'il y a un
congrès des maires de France alors je
vous propose qu'on en fasse tous les six
mois
[Applaudissements]
je crains malheureusement que toutes ces
annonces soient pour beaucoup
que des effets qui seront payés en
billets de Monopoly
regardez de près chacune des annonces
qui nous sont faites soit elles sont
pour un futur
soit nous assistons à un certain nombre
de recyclage prenons le filet de
sécurité au départ c'était 22 000
communes puis ça a été 18000 puis ça a
été 12000 puis ça a été 8000 maintenant
on nous dit peut-être 7000 et moi je
vous dis tel qu'il est si on dépasse
5000 ça sera déjà un exploit
430 millions soi-disant pour compenser
pour l'ensemble des collectivités
territoriales pas seulement les communes
le point d'indice et le point d'indice
pour l'ensemble des collectivités
territoriales c'est 2 milliards 300
donc même si c'est 430 millions trouvés
preneurs ont aujourd'hui on sait que ce
n'est pas le cas c'est pour ça que le
gouvernement essaie de revoir les
critères même si les 430 millions
trouvaient preneur dis-je nous serions
très loin d'une véritable compensation
des 2 milliards 300 millions qu'a coûté
et c'était une action nécessaire à
l'égard des personnels territoriaux la
révision du point d'indice
en fait filer de sécurité c'est une
épuisette à maille très large
et dans lequel peu d'entre nous serons
bien entendu pris en compte
le fond vert tu l'as évoqué et tu as dit
que j'apporterais des précisions je vais
le faire je tiens toujours mes
engagements même ceux qu'on prend pour
moi
le fond vert c'est une bonne idée en soi
on vous a d'abord annoncé un milliard
et puis moi j'avais expertisé et j'étais
arrivé à 600 millions de recyclage on me
dit c'est pas tout à fait ça
en tout cas à coup sûr c'est au minimum
300 millions de recyclage et puis
maintenant on nous dit on y met 500
millions de plus
alors là je vous le dis très clairement
c'est 500 millions c'est un hold-up
pourquoi
tout simplement parce que c'est 500
millions qui vient de en plus
se répanner sur l'argent que l'État a
déjà touché pour la CVAE qui devrait
nous être distribués en 2023
500 millions ponctionnés sur la CVAE qui
devrait nous revenir en 2023 j'ai
regardé à nouveau toutes les notes et
j'affirme ici
que demain nous ne serons pas compensés
à l'Europe auprès en ce qui concerne la
CVA parce qu'à partir du moment où vous
soustrait 500 millions c'est soi-disant
ce qu'il y en plus cette année mais ce
plus il est à nous il est pas à l'état
alors on ne dit mais on vous le remet
sur un fond mais vous savez combien il y
a de crédit de paiement en 2023 inscrit
au budget alors qu'on nous annonce deux
milliards et bien le chiffre exact
inscrit aujourd'hui au budget de la
France dans le cadre de la loi de
finance c'est 375 millions
300 75 millions
et tous les jours on communique sur un
milliard 500 millions d'abord sur 2
milliards en Suisse
moi quand j'étais enfant sur les
fortifications ça existait à l'époque
on appelait ça le jeu du bonneteau
ce n'est pas glorieux
artifice de communication là aussi
alors oui il y a quelques progrès
320 millions sur la DGF
j'ai dit ce que j'en pensais compte tenu
de ce que ça représente j'ajoute
d'ailleurs que je me réjouis pour la DSR
qu'il y a une rallonge et que je ne
comprends pas pourquoi la DSU n'aurait
pas elle aussi une rallonge de même
ampleur alors que s'il y a de la misère
dans nos zones rurales nous savons qu'il
y a aussi beaucoup de misère dans nos
villes et donc le minimum serait au
moins qu'il soit fait un effort
proportionnel équivalent pour les
communes qui sont en dotation de
solidarité
urbaine
voilà
à la vérité aucune de nos revendications
n'a été réellement prise en compte
écoutez oui
Geoffroy qui était avec moi dans ces
réunions pierre Breteau peuvent
confirmer que nous avons été écoutés
longuement
et manifestement rien en est sorti
d'année en année nous sommes de plus en
plus réduits à être une variable
d'ajustement de simples budget annexes
de l'État
la pire des tutelles c'est la tutelle
financière parce qu'elle englobe toutes
les autres il n'est pas de liberté sans
moyens je suis souvent cette phrase de
Camus qui disait supprimer le pain du
travailleur que lui reste-t-il de
liberté et bien nous sommes dans ce cas
de figure ou peu à peu pour nous
supprime la capacité de l'autonomie et
donc de la liberté
ce recul des moyens et des libertés
s'apparente aux supplice du garrot
et pour beaucoup de nos collectivités
l'étouffement financier là
et pour la première fois la question qui
se pose que nous nous posons tous
ensemble et comment vais-je d'habitude
quand on prépare notre budget on se dit
comment vais-je améliorer les services à
la population
et cette année pour beaucoup d'entre
nous peut-être sans doute tous nous nous
disons mais quel service vais-je devoir
affaiblir ou amputé
c'est une extraordinaire régression
et maintenant et ça m'amène à ma
conclusion
et maintenant
le temps d'une véritable négociation ne
serait-il pas venu
il n'y en a pas il y a des conversations
il faut sortir des faux-semblants des
pseudos concertation qui ne servent qu'à
tenter de masquer la verticalité du
pouvoir
la méfiance est parfois le mépris de
l'État à l'égard des collectivités
locales sont je le dis sans engage un
poison qui ronge la France
cette négociation elle est urgente elle
doit donner vie à une grande avancée des
libertés locales consécration
constitutionnelle de la commune cellule
de base de la démocratie
autonomie financière et fiscale
fin de la tutelle préfectorale mise en
œuvre d'un principe simple
qui paie commente paix
vous allez me dire l'objectif est
ambitieux oui il est de libérer les
énergies de libérer les initiatives
d'impulser un véritable mouvement
d'émancipation
n'a rien à y perdre mais la France a
tout à y gagner
la MF a un rôle essentiel à jouer dans
cette période troublée partant de crise
et de division celui de Paul de
stabilité de la République en s'appuyant
sur nos mères les élus les personnels
municipaux qui sont la première ligne de
défense de nos concitoyens
c'est forte de son unité de son plus
rallisme que nous devront encore
aujourd'hui ici que nous avons
la volonté
d'utiliser le pouvoir d'agir d'utiliser
le pouvoir d'agir avec combativité et
liberté pour que l'audace d'ouvrir de
nouveaux espaces d'innovation de
solidarité et de fraternité l'emporte
nos communes portent les valeurs
fondamentales de la démocratie de la
laïcité au quotidien du vivre ensemble
toutes nos exigences tiennent en ces
deux mots pouvoir agir
pouvoir agir pour aider à construire une
république plus humaine fraternelle
juste que nous concitoyens d'outre-mer
et de métropole appellent de leurs vœux
cet horizon pardonnez-moi peut sembler
où aujourd'hui bien
utopique et lointain
certains n'hésiteront sans doute pas à
me traiter de rêveur
je leur réponds simplement avec
Saint-Exupéry
fait que le rêve dévore votre vie afin
que la vie ne dévore pas notre rêve
alors ensemble faisons d'une rêve une
action pour transformer la réalité et
faisons cause commune pour la République
et pour la France
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci
merci Audrey Daniel après le temps des
discours voici le temps des échanges
vous pouvez poser vos questions
témoigner proposer il y a cette espace
pour cela et un premier sujet oui
premier sujet de cette séquence on en a
déjà largement parlé les mères face à
l'inflation face à l'explosion des coups
de l'énergie malgré les dispositifs dont
vous venez de vous faire l'écho filet
amortisseurs les mers sont inquiets
comme mon font les élus comment faites
vous vous allez pouvoir tous intervenir
sur ce sujet après ce film avec les
témoignages de vos collègues de
Vénissieux et de Pontarlier
l'inflation accélérée encore les
collectivités face à l'inflation appel
taled le cri d'alarme des associations
des luttes beaucoup expriment de la
colère et du désarroi
depuis des mois l'escalade des prix de
l'énergie dans finit plus l'inflation et
les prix extrêmement élevés de l'énergie
conséquence du conflit en Ukraine mais
tempériles les finances de très
nombreuses communes
nous sur la ville de Pontarlier premier
objectif c'est économiser sur l'énergie
donc on a pris des mesures de limitation
de température dans les locaux publics
on a pris des mesures de limitation de
l'éclairage de limitation des heures
d'ouverture de certaines salles le soir
mais je pense qu'on a besoin vraiment
d'un changement de braquer si je puis
dire sur les usages qu'on a des locaux
publics pour la première fois en 2022
j'ai dû retravailler trois fois le
budget dans l'année je n'avais jamais
connu ça et je crains qu'en 2023 nous
soyons aussi obligés de faire des
décisions modificatives parce que rien
ne nous garantit que le budget que nous
faisons maintenant à les coût réels de
l'énergie par exemple les collectivités
face à l'inflation appel à l'aide à la
fin c'est le risque c'est moins de
services publics pour les citoyens
on va progresser les demandes d'aide en
bon alimentaire ou en bon financier au
niveau du CCAS on sait que et ça va être
un vrai défi pour les collectivités qui
d'un côté voit diminuer leur recette
voire progresser de manière
exponentielle leur charge de
fonctionnement mais d'un autre côté ils
doivent aussi répondre à des attentes
exprimées par la population en
particulier dans le domaine du social
sont les deux derniers mois j'ai une
augmentation de 5 environ 5% des
effectifs la restauration scolaire c'est
que comme j'ai annoncé que j'ai une
augmentais pas les tarifs des restes de
la restauration scolaire ils sont
relativement modestes des familles
aujourd'hui qui n'avaient pas leurs
enfants à la cantine les y inscrivent
les gens conclus que c'est évidemment
parce que ça leur réduit leur propre
coût
pour l'inflation augmente la charge de
la dette augmente aussi il nous faut à
la fois tenir les comptes et continuer
d'investir
ce mouvement de baisse de
l'investissement je crains qui dure dans
le temps mais en tout cas sur 2023 oui
on va baisser l'investissement sur la
ville de Pontarlier il est vrai qu'il y
a des choses que nous ne ferons pas dès
2023 dans des politiques publiques nous
savons aussi parce que dans le même
temps l'aide sociale augmente il nous
faudra pouvoir augmenter notre budget
sur ces questions là donc il y a pas des
renoncements mais des délais des
décalages dans le temps qui sont quand
même des difficultés et il faut donc
nous restions stables c'est impératif
dans les temps qui viennent pour la
future cohésion du pays
et vous quand dites vous qu'en
dites-vous de des difficultés
financières mais aussi de la des normes
et des problèmes qui se posent
aujourd'hui dans la gestion locale vous
avez la parole c'est l'espace de débat
qui vous est proposé l'espace des
questions et une première intervention
vous vous présentez s'il vous plaît oui
bonsoir monsieur le Président bonsoir à
tous chers collègues Françoise le couple
mère de Limeil-Brévannes présidente de
l'Association des Maires du Val-de-Marne
ma question est assez simple allons nous
continuer d'assister impuissant à la
disparition de l'échelon communale nous
nous sommes laissés enfermer dans un
certain nombre
d'intercommunalités qui s'approprie nos
compétences de façon disparate et
parfois désordonnée
je ne vais pas revenir sur les questions
de DGF ou encore de taxes d'aménagement
avec les complexités qui viennent avec
toujours dans la subtilité par exemple
l'état vient de rompre l'accord passé
avec les employeurs territoriaux
concernant le financement de
l'apprentissage c'est juste un petit
exemple parmi tant d'autres du mépris
avec lequel nous sommes
considérés
nos ressources stables sont remplacées
comme il a été dit par des appels à
projets et ce n'est pas seulement un
problème pour les villes qui manquent
d'ingénierie c'est aussi une façon de
faire de nous insérer dans un réseau
d'obligation sans que nous ayons le
choix finalement des projets que nous
voulons faire voilà on décide un appel à
projet sur tel ou telle politique
publique pas forcément sur une autre
aujourd'hui nos ressources vont être
englouties dans des dépenses
énergétiques et l'inflation donc ça a
été répété dit mais chacun dans nos
villes nous le voyons et nous sommes en
grande difficulté pour boucler nos
budgets
dans le même temps nous promet donc un
pacte de Cahors et le gouvernement nous
explique que nous devrions baisser nos
taux d'imposition de taxe foncières pour
compenser la hausse des bases qui va
suivre l'infraction on voit la manœuvre
nous rendent responsables de
l'augmentation de cette taxe et bien
vous voyez c'est les mers qui augmentent
c'est eux c'est une forme de mise sous
tutelle moi je n'ai pas peur de le dire
une mise sous tutelle d'avance on va
dire avant même que nous ayons commencé
à faire quelque chose
face à la crise énergique énergétique
nous craignons de perdre le rôle
d'amortisseur humain et social que nous
nous appliquons à exercer depuis
toujours lors du premier confinement
avec les centres sociaux et les CCAS les
communes ont été les seuls
administrations à conserver un lien
physique avec les usagers nous avons
tenu la maison quand même le dire notre
Président l'isna nous l'avons vraiment
tenu
mais aujourd'hui en continuant à
asphyxier financièrement les communes
est-ce leur disparition programmée qui
est décidé
j'attire donc ici l'attention de nos
représentants nationaux sur le fait que
pour les communes le contenu est pas et
que j'attends que notre voix soit portée
de façon énergique comment allons-nous
nous faire entendre est-il raisonnable
de penser que seuls d'autres étapes de
négociation vont permettre de changer le
système dans lequel nous sommes enfermés
et de procéder à la fin de la
concentration avec un petit minimum de
décentralisation merci en tout cas votre
parole a été entendue dans cette salle
dans cet auditorium on va prendre une
autre intervention
[Applaudissements]
allez-y monsieur vous présenter s'il
vous plaît
bonjour je suis Monsieur Georges Morin
je suis maire d'une petite commune de
240 habitants
je suis maire depuis 20 ans je viens
régulièrement au Congrès des Maires de
France j'écoute j'observe j'entends
mais quand je reviens chez moi je suis
je dirais fort des pourvu parce que
quand on vient de dire il faut pouvoir
agir
il se pose une grosse problématique pour
nos communes qui n'ont pas de recette
annexes c'est à dire qu'ils n'ont pour
recette que la DGF et que les impôts
on arrive au bout du bout je vais vous
donner un exemple tout simple
je suis président nassimum pour les
travaux de Boiry je l'avais déjà parlé
l'année dernière on était à peu près à
300000 euros il y a 4-5 ans et là on
arrive à 90000 euros de travaux et dans
les 90.000 euros
quelles sont les communes qui peuvent le
faire ce sont les communes qui ont des
ressources annexes importantes à savoir
des forêts des pylônes mais pour le
reste on est obligé de faire l'impasse
donc la DGF qui devrait normalement
faire une péricquation et nous permettre
au moins d'avoir un autofinancement qui
nous permettent d'investir le minimum on
demande pas de faire des piscines en
demande pas de faire
des grands investissements on demande
simplement de faire nos rues nos routes
et on est obligé de faire l'impasse
parce qu'on a plus les moyens pouvoir
agir c'est avoir au moins un
autofinancement qui nous permettent
d'avoir des actions
alors cette DGF qu'on entend parler
depuis longtemps il faut la réformer
tout le monde s'aperçoit que toute façon
elle ne correspond plus à rien mais
personne ne veut la faire parce que tout
le monde a peur de perdre en particulier
les grandes villes les villes moyennes
mais nous les petits les petites
communes on n'en peut plus on peut plus
investir vous voulez qu'on ait des
chemins blancs quand vous allez venir
chez nous alors j'ai vu le ministre qui
donnait des
des subventions pour retirer les les
bétons des écoles des cours d'école il y
a longtemps qu'on en a jamais mis nous
on va peut-être avoir une subvention
parce qu'on va voir des chemins blancs
on va retirer du plus sérieusement ce
qui serait intéressant de la NF de l'AMF
c'est de mettre comme dans résolution de
revoir un petit peu cette DGF de façon
qu'on puisse retrouver une autonomie on
ne demande pas un miracle mais on est on
a même pas le SMIC on est au RSA c'était
de commune et si vous faites rien on
aboutit rom on va défendre des communes
on va défendre des communes de toute
façon on pourra plus rien faire
merci merci
et pour pour réagir à ces témoignages
pour répondre aussi à cette question sur
la question de l'autonomie financière
des petites communes j'invite dijoffroy
peut-être à répondre qu'au président du
comité législatif de l'AMF maire de
Combs-la-Ville je vous invite à répondre
voilà une réponse consiste parce que
beaucoup de vos collègues souhaitent
s'exprimer
la réponse sera je l'espère précise et
en tout cas concise je reprends le
propos d'Andrey Daniel tout à l'heure
oui on nous consacre du temps pour
dialoguer c'est vrai
on nous fait des annonces on prend des
engagements c'est vrai ma réponse c'est
en direction du gouvernement chiche
allons-y chiche et c'est bien pour cela
d'ailleurs que nous avons décidé tous
ensemble en passé de créer ce comité
législatif et réglementaire pour non pas
attendre que le gouvernement ou le
Parlement propose des choses et que nous
essayons de trouver le moyen de donner
notre petit avis sans savoir s'il va en
être tenu compte mais pour prendre les
devants et faire des propositions alors
moi je voudrais faire une proposition à
tous les présidents d'associations
départementales qui sont ici concernant
justement le fond vert et l'engagement
pris par le gouvernement réitéré ce
matin par Christophe Béchu d'inverser
les choses c'est à dire de ne plus être
verticale en partant d'en haut mais
d'être vertical en partant du bas et
bien que tous les présidents
d'associations départementales fasse ce
que j'ai fait dans mon département que
d'autres ont fait prennent contact avec
le préfet pour dire Monsieur le Préfet
le ministre nous a dit que comment on va
faire dans notre département parce que
nous voulons avec vous mettre sur la
table les bases d'un véritable travail
parlant partant des réalités du terrain
pour répartir les crédits dont enfin on
nous dit qu'ils ne seront pas fléchés
avec obligation pour nous de cocher
toutes les cases mais tonton nous dit ça
partira de chez vous comme ça part de
chez nous chiche voilà merci
Guy Geoffroy alors c'est à vous monsieur
vous présentez bonjour à tous Alexis
matoul je suis le maire de Saint-Jean la
poterie dans le Morbihan c'est mon
premier mandat et je suis également
membre du bureau de la MF du département
alors ma question c'est plus une
réflexion ça ne concerne pas tant les
marges financières que le pouvoir d'agir
au sens large j'aimerais vous donner un
chiffre ce chiffre c'est 4 dans mon
département il y a depuis le début du
mandat 4 démission par semaine on en est
à presque 600 élus conseillers
municipaux mais adjoint qui ont
démissionné depuis le début du mandat
des chiffres qui sont en énorme
augmentation depuis le précédent alors
les remontées qu'il y a au au niveau de
la MF départemental un mot qui revient
c'est le mot de découragement c'est le
découragement face à la complexité de
l'univers dans lequel évolue l'élu c'est
une complexité juridique complexité
réglementaire c'est le découragement
face aux incivilités qui grandissent
c'est le découragement face à la
violence envers les élus qui et on en
parlera tout à l'heure votre message est
très clair Monsieur le Maire alors c'est
quelque chose que j'imagine vous devez
également avoir au niveau national ma
réflexion c'est il y a le statut des lui
bien évidemment sur lequel il faut qu'on
travaille parce qu'il y a les questions
d'indemnité il y a des questions de
formation il y a des questions de
couverture sociale des choses qui sont
extrêmement concrètes mais qui ont un
impact réel sur la vie des maires au
quotidien il y a également une réflexion
plus large des réflexions plus larges à
avoir sur comment est-ce que l'AMF agit
pour lutter contre ces incivilités pour
lutter contre la violence on a beaucoup
parlé de de la grande démission des
salariés et
il faut vraiment qu'on se prenne par la
main pour que le mandat prochaine ne
soit pas la grande démission des élus
merci Monsieur le Maire on va pas se
prendre une autre question une autre
intervention
[Applaudissements]
et c'est une intervention qui vient des
Outre-mer
bonjour je me présente Jocelyn sapoti
président de l'Association des maires de
Guadeloupe et mère de la commune de
Lamentin j'ai écouté avec beaucoup
d'attention trop collègues André lenière
sur la question bien sûr
du pouvoir d'agir et ça m'amène tout
simplement à réfléchir aussi non
seulement
de la capacité financière que nous avons
pour agir mais de la capacité que nous
avons aussi à agir par rapport à la
réglementation par rapport à l'existence
du normes et aujourd'hui il y a un débat
au niveau de l'État sur la révision des
normes la révision bien sûr
certainement de la Constitution et ma
demande c'est que nous-mer et que nous
soyons
fortement accompagnés par la MF
que nous soyons totalement parti pour
notre de cette réflexion de cette
discussion sur la réforme de la
Constitution qui doit conduire à plus de
liberté locale qui doit conduire à la
révision des normes et à l'adaptation
des normes selon les territoires ce
débat est premium dans les outre-mer
mais comme j'ai eu l'occasion à le dire
et à l'exprimer auprès de l'AMF que je
remercie d'ailleurs qui nous a suivi
pour la création de la délégation
outre-mer au sein de la MF ce débat ne
concerne pas uniquement les outre-mer
mais concerne tous les territoires et
tous les territoires en France qui
veulent évoluer sur la question des
normes pour adapter les normes pour nous
donner ce pouvoir d'agir non seulement
avec les capacités financières mais
aussi avec les normes qui sont adaptés à
nos territoires pour nous permettre
d'être efficients et de mettre en place
des politiques publiques avec des
résultats les résultats qu'attendent nos
administrer monsieur le Président et
tout collègue tous les collègues ici
présent c'est le vœu ici que j'exprime
merci Monsieur le Maire voilà et sur ce
sujet de l'attractivité sur la question
du statut de l'élu j'invite Catherine
Vautrin à répondre vice-présidente de
l'AMF présidente du Grand REIMS merci
d'abord à nos collègues parce que ils
mettent en avant des sujets qu'on
rencontre tous les jours c'est vrai que
les élus sont de plus en plus
interpellés et ils sont interpellés à la
fois par l'impatience de nos concitoyens
l'élu ça reste celui de proximité qui
est toujours là et nous sommes également
interpellés sur des sujets je fais le
lien avec les normes sur des sujets dont
l'État n'a pas lui-même les réponses je
vais prendre un exemple très précis
c'est celui de l'eau je ne sais pas si
vous êtes nombreux à avoir sur votre
territoire par exemple le sujet des
métabolites si quelqu'un aujourd'hui est
capable de nous donner une réponse sur
les métabolites et bien je le vois avec
grand bonheur parce que vous discutez
avec la RS qui vous explique que vous ne
respectez pas les normes mais qui ne
sait pas vous dire quels sont les
éléments que vous devez prendre quelles
sont les voix et les moyens que vous
devez prendre donc derrière tout ça en
élu consciencieux que nous sommes et
toutes nos équipes avec nous nous
cherchons évidemment le mieux possible
on va pas laisser imaginer et faire
penser à nos concitoyens qu'on délivre
une eau qui n'est pas potable et en même
temps on n'a pas capacité à avoir cette
certitude que nous prenons les bonnes
réponses au bon moment donc oui notre
collègue a parfaitement raison c'est une
discussion de partenaire à partenaire
nous avons démontré pendant le covid que
ceux qui avaient été capables d'inventer
en marchant et d'apporter des solutions
c'était précisément les élus de terrain
parce que nous avons avec l'ARS avec
l'État local eu la capacité à travailler
et je crois que la réflexion que l'État
doit mener c'est de se dire
qu'aujourd'hui le préfet notamment le
préfet de département est assez seul et
que sans l'accompagnement des
collectivités quelle que soit sa bonne
volonté il est compliqué d'avancer
d'apporter des solutions donc moi si je
lui dis monsieur le Préfet on est à
votre disposition à condition que nous
puissions discuter armes égales ça passe
par le respect des élus ça passe par la
révision des normes dialogues entre les
collectivités et l'État renouveler merci
Catherine votre vous avez la parole
monsieur le maire de Cahors oui bonjour
je m'appelle
maire de Cahors président de l'AMF 46 et
de la MF
Occitanie pour pouvoir agir il faut
aussi pouvoir se former et c'est pour
cela que je souhaitais vous interpeller
sur les nombreuses difficultés
auxquelles sont confrontées les élus qui
souhaitent mobiliser leurs droits
individuel à la formation je veux
revenir sur les faits nous avons appris
le 24 octobre dernier qu'a compté du 25
octobre donc dès le lendemain sans
aucune anticipation sans aucune
préparation que tout élu soit en
s'inscrire à une session de formation au
titre du DIF
deux vies s'identifier avec France
Connect plus ce qui impose la création
préalable d'une identité numérique de la
poste
le 7 janvier 2022 nous avons subi déjà
la mise en place de la plateforme mon
compte élu outils
pour nous et qui avait déjà constitué un
frein à la description en formation mais
désormais avec les rocambolesques et
parfois infranchissable étape de
création de l'identité numérique la
poste il ne s'agit plus d'un frein et
d'un véritable coût d'arrêt qui est
porté à notre droit individuel à la
formation petit retour de terrain si
vous voulez bien pour les élus qui
tentent de s'identifier en ligne et qui
sont confrontés à des bugs ou de
difficultés une hotline avait été mise
en place par la poste mais elle est
clairement sous-dimensionnée nous
adhérents me font remonter qu'il passe
parfois plus de d'une demi-heure en
attente sans même parvenir à joindre
quelqu'un et je peux vous dire que dans
le Lot je n'ai pas trouvé un seul élu
qui réussit à se connecter à cette
hotline puis vous allez ceux qui
l'effort c'est une autre possibilité de
se rendre jusqu'à leur bureau de poste
ou les attentes de les conseiller la
poste mais qui sont également confrontés
au bug et qui ne parviennent pas à avoir
non plus un résultat positif donc on
demande aux élus de revenir deux fois
trois fois et puis le résultat c'est
qu'au bout d'un moment il lâche
l'affaire
par ailleurs lorsque nous avons franchi
cette étape nous sommes ensuite
confrontés aux dysfonctionnements de la
plateforme nationale mon compte élu donc
si la hotline ne répond pas
c'est ensuite du côté de nos
associations des départementales et de
nos équipes que les élus se tournent
avec un travail considérable à effectuer
qui n'est pas toujours garantie de
succès je peux vous dire qu'aujourd'hui
beaucoup d'élus sont en train de jeter
l'éponge et que c'est une problématique
parce que je rappelle que le droit
individuel à la formation devrait être
facilement mobilisable il est je le
rappelle financé par des prélèvements
effectués sur nos zeldanités de fonction
les conditions matérielles de l'exercice
de ce droit à la formation merci
Monsieur question qui s'adresse à Muriel
Fabre là secrétaire général de l'AMF oui
merci effectivement cette question de
droit à la formation est aujourd'hui une
question complexe pour nos élus je
voudrais tout d'abord rappeler que la MF
est attachée à ce gif est attaché à la
formation des élus et nous avons fait là
encore preuve d'une absence de
concertation en tout cas d'anticipation
puisque nous avons découvert
effectivement le 19 octobre que cette
plateforme France Connect pour des
raisons en fait de sécurisation au
départ des données n'étaient pas
adaptées devaient se transformer en
France Connect plus donc quelques jours
juste avant la mise en oeuvre on a
sollicité des délais qui n'ont
évidemment pas été pris en compte et
aujourd'hui on se retrouve face à une
difficulté et le bilan est effectivement
assez négatif puisque depuis plus d'un
mois nos élus n'ont pu accès à cette
plateforme et c'était déjà une
difficulté pour mon compte formation
parce que je le rappelle pour les élus
certaines avaient complètement disparu
en fait du système de données oui
effectivement on avait oublié que nous
sommes aussi pas forcément sous nos noms
Maritain mais sous nos noms de jeunes
voilà donc
très concrète et les freins donc juste
confirmer que nous allons évidemment
prendre ce sujet à coeur le ministère
des collectivités territoriales et déjà
d'ailleurs dans la boucle et on va
solliciter aussi évidemment des
substitutions voir des compensations
parce qu'il est inadmissible que nous ne
pouvons pas bénéficier de ce DIF donc si
nous pouvons pas bénéficier en 2022 il
faudra bien évidemment qu'il se rajoute
à 2023 c'est ce qu'on sait ce qu'on fera
la nécessité en même temps d'avoir des
garanties des sécurités pour éviter des
fraudes dont serait victime les élus
eux-mêmes c'est à vous monsieur je vous
invite à intervenir plutôt brièvement et
avoir des réponses assez brèves aussi
afin que nous puissions faire intervenir
le maximum de personnes merci bonjour à
toutes et à tous
Jean-Marc Labé maire de la commune de La
Méaugon dans les Côtes-d'Armor
vice-présidente agglomération en charge
des politiques de l'énergie et de la
transition écologique et du PCET et
vice-président également du syndicat
départemental d'énergie des
Côtes-d'Armor alors vous remarquerez que
j'ai mis un déroulé et j'essaie
d'appliquer les consignes
gouvernementales et pour autant j'ai
quelques questions sur l'énergie face à
la crise énergétique et par souci de
relocalisation de production d'énergie
de nombreuses collectivités communes
EPCI syndicat départementaux d'énergie
souhaite produire davantage sur leur
territoire et réduire leur dépendance
qui aujourd'hui nous coûtent cher
en Bretagne nous sommes une péninsule
énergétique ou notre dépendance nous a
déjà impacté et nous devrions l'être à
nouveau dans les semaines à venir sur la
région de Saint-Brieuc nous avons
souhaité produire de l'hydrogène vert à
partir d'énergie exclusivement
renouvelable aujourd'hui sur ce sujet
nous sommes confrontés à un appel à
projets piloté par l'ADEME repoussez
bientôt depuis un an pour nous
accompagner donc la dame doit nous
accompagner sur ce projet mais
l'appel le projet est sans cesse
repousser et nous n'avons pas de
visibilité quant à sa parution
pourtant nous collectivités nous sommes
prêts en attendant des mégafactory sont
aidés avec le risque dans quelques
années d'être dépendant à nouveau des
prix pratiqués par ces grands groupes
internationaux il en va de même pour la
création de books énergétique local et
Olia nous sommes en train de
photovoltaïque au périmètre trop
restreint des collectivités veulent
investir via des scènes ou des SPL afin
de mieux contrôler maîtriser arbitrer
les cours futurs de l'énergie c'est très
clair donc des projets locaux qui
doivent pouvoir exister les questions
les questions qui émergent de ces
constats sont les suivantes comment la
MF peut-elle faire pression pour aider
les collectivités à se faire accompagner
notamment en aidant l’ingénierie de nos
collectivités et en accentant la
formation sur les métiers d'énergie et
comment la MF peut faire comprendre à
nos ministères que les collectivités
doivent être parties prenantes dans les
investissements et que l'État doit les
aider de façon plus rapide nos délais
d'instructions sont deux fois plus
longues qu'en Allemagne et nous aider de
façon plus pragmatique et opérationnelle
dans les financements merci Monsieur le
Maire on prend une autre intervention
allez-y vous passez le micro à votre
collègue
bonjour Philippe Chalopin donc maire de
la commune nouvelle le Beaujon d'Anjou
le champion des communes nouvelles je ne
sais pas si c'est le champion mais en
tout cas j'ai le plaisir aussi de
composer le groupe de travail de l'AMF
et puis je suis également président de
l'Association des maires de
Maine-et-Loire je voulais réagir à la
diffusion la parution d'un rapport de
l'Inspection générale de
l'administration en septembre dernier
qui vient nous expliquer que les
communes nouvelles ça ne fonctionne pas
que ça coûte cher qu'on embauche
beaucoup que il est normal que notre DGF
diminue et que de toute façon on n'a pas
d'avenir alors moi je suis très inquiet
parce que les communes nouvelles
aujourd'hui sous l'impulsion de l'AMF
c'est quand même un peu plus de 800 aux
communes c'est 2300 c'est beaucoup plus
de 1300 comme une regroupés c'est
beaucoup plus que les communes de la
dite de la loi Marcelin et si l'état
effectivement décide de ne compliquer
les démarches on va pas s'en sortir
alors ce qu'on demande euh elle a MF
peut-être un formidable soutien c'est
d'une part que l'État soit facilitateur
de nos démarches parce que créer une
commune nouvelle ce n'est pas simple et
que l'État aussi
clarifie les règles on ne peut pas
changer systématiquement les règles sur
les dotations on les fixe une fois pour
toute on passe un accord de règlement il
y a pas de difficulté mais il faut
effectivement que l'État
reste enfin garde des règles claires et
ne viennent pas créer parce que le
rapport et j'en aurai terminé le rapport
préconise la constitution d'une
commission départementale qui viendrait
de temps en temps à Dubé tel ou telle
regroupement donc on est radicalement
contre et je compte bien évidemment sur
le soutien du président de la MF pour
faire en sorte que nos communes
nouvelles puissent continuer à se
développer parce que elle aussi ont un
certain pouvoir d'action merci Monsieur
Chalopin on prend d'autres interventions
allez-y vous vous présentez bonjour
Tristan Duval maire de Cabourg je vais
vous rassurer je vais faire des phrases
beaucoup plus courtes que Marcel Proust
juste pour vous de parler un sujet c'est
le problème d'attractivité de la
fonction publique territoriale nous
sommes de plus en plus confrontés là
aussi il y a des démissions notamment
sur tous les sujets liés à l'urbanisme
la semaine de quatre jours le covid le
télétravail pose énormément de problèmes
il y a une concurrence de plus en plus
forte entre les collectivités les
intercos ou les départements et les
régions et je voudrais que on puisse
évoquer un peu ce sujet là parce que ça
pose des gros problèmes d'organisation
sur les projets sur lesquels l'État nous
demande de plus en plus et de plus en
plus exigeant donc c'est un sujet sur
lequel on est vraiment avec des gros
problèmes d'embauche et l'attractivité
de la fonction publique territoriale
devient de plus en plus compliquée
surtout sur ces métiers là merci
alors beaucoup de questions déjà oui sur
la première question qui concernait donc
le sujet de l'énergie lucarguna
savez-vous quelque chose à répondre à ce
sujet
au collègues maire qui intervenu je
l'invite à se rapprocher au salon des
mers du céréma qui est un établissement
public gouvernemental et qui fournit
justement de l'ingénierie très précieuse
pour les collectivités territoriales
ensuite sur toute la question
énergétique tous les bars que nous
sommes ici dans cette salle je crois que
on n'a pas attendu cette nouvelle
expression de plans sobriété pour se
mettre à niveau que ce sont les
questions de géothermie du
photovoltaïque de changer les nos LED
dans les candélabres etc etc mais je
finirai par là ce qui est en train de se
qui va se produire dans les semaines
prochaines et là je le dis avec ma
casquette de co-président de la
commission affaire sociale et le
président de l'unica c'est qu'on ne sont
pas compte des indicateurs de pauvreté
qui sont en train d'arriver à bas bruit
j'en parlais avec la délégué
interministérielle à la pauvreté et
c'est pour cela et le collègue le disait
très bien à l'écran le collèguemaire
c'est que malheureusement avec l'après
covid les gens pensent que maintenant
les mers nous pouvons répondre à tout et
avec la suppression de la taxe
d'habitation en plus il pense que c'est
gratuit or aujourd'hui on va avoir une
précarité qui va venir malheureusement
frapper à nos portes de nos
municipalités et je ne connais pas une
seule collectivité qui n'a pas ces deux
dernières années a bondé son budget de
CCAS justement pour répondre à la fois
la crise sanitaire à la crise
environnementale ce sont les CCAS et les
CS qui ont été sollicités par les
pouvoirs publics pour accueillir les
Afghans les Afghans les les Ukrainiens
etc etc donc à un moment donné
l'équation financière telle qu'elle a
été dressée par le président l'islain et
notre premier vice REP paysan André
lenial ça ne fonctionne pas et ce qui
est en train de se produire et c'est ma
conclusion c'est qu'on arrive à une
déconnexion totale du législateur et de
ceux qui font qui font société dans les
territoires et c'est malheureusement une
conséquence néfaste du Parlement du
non-cumul
autre question qui qui a été posée celle
qui concernait les communes nouvelles
Joël balandro pouvez-vous répondre à
cette question
oui alors répondre à une question de
Philippe sur les communes nouvelles
c'est difficile forcément mais moi-même
moi-même maire d'une commune nouvelle il
sait qu'on partage les mêmes combats il
y a une spécificité à avoir les communes
nouvelles c'est l'expression d'une
liberté de faire ensemble donc il faut
forcément si on parle de liberté donc de
responsabilité de faire ensemble et que
les moyens ils soient donnés à cette
liberté et cette responsabilité donc on
partage les combats Philippe je sais que
c'est le mot de chacun ici autour du
bureau de l'AMF on défendra les communes
nouvelles on défendra les communes
nouvelle pas nouvelle il y a pas c'est
pas un débat des vieux contre les contre
les jeunes et donc on sera surtout ces
on est on est sur les chemins de liberté
quoi non dans ces questions là donc on
sera derrière et avec Philippe
et puis question d'urbanisme aussi oui
il est sur la fonction publique
territoriale notamment Muriel Fabre
avez-vous une réponse à apporter alors
bien sûr la question d'attractivité
aujourd'hui elle est plaignante aussi
pour nos collectivités et effectivement
si on est sans argent et sans agent
comment allons-nous agir demain c'est
une vraie question alors sur
l'attractivité Philippe Laurent n'est
plus là mais il avait fait avec ma
petite Icare notamment un rapport sur
l'attractivité avec nombre de
propositions dans ce quart d'heure là et
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui on a les
tensions fortes au-delà de la démission
on a des tensions fortes en recrutement
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui on n'arrive
plus à recruter il y a de plus en plus
de métiers en tension certains étaient
déjà identifiés je pense évidemment au
secrétaire de mairie police municipale
gestionnaire RH mais aujourd'hui
effectivement ça se démultiplie sur
l'ensemble de nos postes et ça touche
petite et grande collectivité donc c'est
une question sur lequel nous nous avons
des propositions nous avons des
solutions évidemment ça passe par de la
visibilité aussi c'est-à-dire redonner
du sens aujourd'hui à la fonction
publique territoriale ça passe également
évidemment par des moyens financiers
parce que pour payer nos agents il faut
bien évidemment avoir les finances pour
se faire et je vous invite d'ailleurs au
forum demain sur la fonction publique
territoriale puisque l'attractivité sera
au cœur de notre sujet avec notamment
l'arrivée d'un hicel le port ce qui va
nous rappeler les fondamentaux du statut
ce forum donc rendez-vous est pris
demain c'est à vous monsieur oui bonjour
Jean-Claude Ducard je suis le maire de
Melun en Saône-et-Loire au sud de la
Bourgogne maire depuis 1995 je voulais
juste porter un focus sur une question
qui me tient à cœur qui est le pouvoir
agir pour la relation le maintien du
lien social et la relation au service
public ou au service au public qui se
sont cette relation qui s'est beaucoup
délitée au cours de ces décennies
passées de ces dernières années en
particulier et qui aurait été accentuée
par la crise sanitaire et par
l'évolution vers le tout numérique qui
accentue cette fracture sociale il y a
des réponses pertinentes qui sont
apportées avec notamment les maisons
France service
qui ont été qui ont permis de mutualiser
un certain nombre de choses mais donc
ces évolutions ont permis des
économistes sans doute significatives au
niveau de l'État par rapport à
des administrations avec les postes les
services qui ont été supprimés qui sont
partis de nos territoires en particulier
de nos territoires ruraux donc ces
maisons France services elles ne peuvent
fonctionner que si elle fonctionne avec
des personnels avec des postes pérennes
avec une professionnalisation et je
voulais juste attirer l'attention de
notre assemblée sur le soutien financier
qui est apporté à ces maisons France
services qui me paraît insuffisant je
sais que la MF a sollicité une
revalorisation de l'indemnité de l'État
au titre de ces maisons France services
pour permettre d'apporter justement de
pouvoir agir sur ce lien social et sur
cette relation au service au public et
au service public voilà je vous l'ai dit
de moyen pour cette nouvelle relation à
l'usager on prend encore
une proposition une question un
témoignage allez-y monsieur
Jean-Louis maire de Saint-Claude Jura
c'est une au département que connaît
bien le Président il connaît tous les
départements maintenant le président
mais c'est vrai il a travaillé chez nous
donc voilà moi c'est une supplique que
je lui adresse simplement est-ce qu'on
est-ce que vous pouvez vous qui êtes
écouté même si vous n'êtes pas entendu
par le gouvernement demandez au
gouvernement de mettre coup de frein sur
le tout numérique c'est plus possible
40% de la population est éloignée du
numérique pour des raisons de la des
raisons de compétences des raisons
d'équipements aujourd'hui on n'en peut
plus on a plus personne en face de soi
qu'il s'agisse de renseignements fiscaux
qu'il s'agisse de toutes sortes de
démarches et on ne peut pas toujours
aboutir moi qui ai enseigné
l'informatique j'ai buté j'ai pas pu
réaliser ma carte grise parce que au
dernier moment il fallait l'envoyer une
pièce jointe qui n'a jamais pu passer
donc le tout numérique il faut un peu
arrêter et pour une deuxième raison j'ai
eu il y a trois jours samedi une panne
générale de tous les réseaux
d'opérateurs Orange Free etc la ville
était paralysée pendant 24 heures on ne
pouvait plus les commerçants n'ont pas
pu se faire payer aucune transaction par
carte bancaire pour faire un plein
d'essence avec la carte vous pouviez pas
remplir votre réservoir le téléphone
mobile le téléphone fixe était HS et y
compris les télétransmission de
l'hôpital vers d'autres hôpitaux pour
transmettre tes résultats d'analyses ne
pourraient plus fonctionner ça m'a fait
en 24 heures mesurer la fragilité de
notre société qui est totalement
informatisée et si un jour on a un gros
coup dur pas comment Ukraine évidemment
mais simplement une acte de terrorisme
avec une destruction de nos systèmes qui
durent plusieurs jours ou plusieurs
semaines nous sommes morts la vie
s'arrête partout alors le numérique oui
l'outil moderne c'est bien je suis pas
contre le progrès mais je crois que
maintenant il va falloir aussi penser à
remettre de la humaine dans les
relations entre les usagers et
l'administration merci merci et
rendez-vous d'ailleurs il y a un débat
dans le Congrès un point faux sur la
cyber sécurité en particulier et sur
cette question de la présence des
services publics et des services aux
citoyens j'invite Jacqueline Bellom à
répondre à ces deux interventions qui se
complétaient
et rapidement
je suis en train de cuire un petit peu
sur le numérique évidemment on constate
on constate dans le Jura on constate
dans les petits villages on constate y
compris même dans nos villes dans nos
villes
et on arrive à avoir effectivement des
citoyens qui se coupent de leurs droits
c'est une multiplication de non recours
au droit et on voit que nos CCAS par
exemple
sont obligés aujourd'hui maintenant de
recevoir par exemple des habitants pour
voir si leurs documents est bien rempli
avant de prendre un rendez-vous avec la
CAF avec la CPAM avec la trésorerie qui
n'est plus sur le territoire mais qu'il
faut qu'ils se connectent et ils se
veulent être sûr de bien pouvoir
répondre aux questions donc c'est un
vrai sujet c'est un vrai enjeu d'égalité
d'égalité y compris de nos citoyens dans
dans nos villes et dans nos territoires
donc évidemment la MF est écouté pas
forcément entendu mais nous évidemment
mobilisés aussi sur cette situation pour
faire entendre que oui la modernité
c'est important mais attention il faut
il faut ralentir franchement parce qu'on
a une coupure qui entraîne ce mettre en
place une rupture très claire il faut
aider aussi à mettre en place des
formations c'est fait dans les villes
c'est fait dans les CCAS c'est fait dans
les maisons de quartier par contre il
faut accompagner aussi bah c'est avec de
l'argent c'est du radium et quand on
enlève des moyens comme ça dans nos
services publics nationaux il faut il
faut et quand on transfère parce que
c'est encore un transfert sur les villes
pour accompagner les gens les aider les
accompagner lutter contre la fracture
numérique très concrètement on prend
encore deux interventions et puis on
avancera dans le débat et puis pendant
ces trois jours vous aurez aussi la
possibilité d'intervenir de faire des
propositions de poser des questions et
bien évidemment c'est le aussi le
Congrès des solutions des solutions que
vous portez c'est à vous monsieur
bonjour à tous Michel Lallemand mère de
huile département des
je voudrais intervenir concernant la
règle nortificialisation des sols qui
limite fortement le développement de nos
communes même si nous comprenons son
unité passe à rigidité notre département
est confronté à la rigueur
incompréhensible de l'architecte des
bâtiments de France qui nous empêche de
réhabiliter le bâti existant de nos
communes rurales sous prétexte ne
pouvoir ni rien modifier nos bâtis vont
être plus tard de futurs ruines
donc un dialogue améliorer avec les
services des architectes des bâtiments
de France voilà que faire contre ce
dicta une très claire Monsieur Votre
propos ce qui est une question mais
aussi une proposition d'amélioration on
prend une dernière intervention
dernière provisoirement puisque là
encore les questions les propositions
que vous portez et bien alimenteront
tous nos débats jusqu'à jeudi allez-y
madame alors Anne-Françoise pied d'alu
je suis maire pour un deuxième mandat de
la presqu'île de Plougrescant dans les
Côtes-d'Armor
mon intervention ce soir est un peu
différente des sujets qui ont été
abordés jusqu'à présent puisque ça
touche une demande que je veux formuler
auprès du président de l'AMF et de son
exécutif je vous ai d'ailleurs adressé
monsieur Lisnard un mail à ce sujet il
s'agit d'une demande de demander au
gouvernement de mettre en place un PPI
national alors un PPI c'est donc un plan
particulier d'intervention qui
aujourd'hui ne concerne que les communes
qui sont dans un rayon de 20 km autour
d'une centrale nucléaire
je demande en ce qui me concerne tout
simplement par respect pour la
population dans un principe de
protection de faire en sorte que ce PPI
soit national et non pas uniquement pour
ses communes dans un contexte
international international tel que
celui qu'on connaît tout à l'heure nous
avons mis à l'honneur à juste titre des
mères des communes du crâne dans ce
cadre là il se trouve que nous en
entendons parler régulièrement encore
sur les plateaux de les télés des
risques de
d'un problème nucléaire d'un nuage
nucléaire disons et nous nous avons été
sollicités sur le département des
Côtes-d'Armor par notre préfet pour
créer une fiche pour notre plan communal
de sauvegarde indiquant la manière dont
nous allions procéder en tant que mère
pour la distribution des comprimés
diodes de potassium
il se trouve que nous très clairement
nous avons été amenés à travailler sur
le sujet et on y travaillant on a été
amené à se poser plein de questions et
des questions celles que je veux vous
monter qui me préoccupe le plus en tant
que mère c'est une question d'éthique en
résumé on nous indique qu'il y a
normalement suffisamment de comprimés
pour toute la population on nous indique
que les comprimés que nous aurions à
distribuer correspondent à la population
Insee sachant que la population une C
pour une commune quand par exemple nous
sommes du littoral et que nous avons des
comme des habitants de résidence
secondaire ce n'est pas la population
Insee et un nombre très précis de
comprimés qui ne seraient amenés à être
attribué et que nous aurions nous en
tant qu'élu la charge de remettre aux
habitants c'est toute la question de la
gestion des risques et du pragmatisme
ma question d'éthique c'est pas celle-là
bon on nous donne cette
[Musique]
alors sur la non artificialisation des
sols ce matin on avait l'échange avec
Christophe Béchu il a clairement dit
qu'il reprenait les décrets qui leur
remettaient sur les métiers et qu'il ne
les promulguerait pas tant qu'il ne nous
les auraient pas fait connaître voilà du
grain à moudre pour le comité législatif
et réglementaire dont nous parlions tout
à l'heure d'ailleurs j'en profite pour
dire que lors de notre dernière réunion
de travail de ce comité nous avons
décidé d'inscrire à notre ordre du jour
deux sujets d'une très grande banalité
d'une très grande facilité un la
décentralisation enfin demain et de le
zan et donc la reprise des travaux du
gouvernement donc on aura notre mot à
dire et nous le dirons
merci Eddy Geoffroy merci mesdames
messieurs nous allons passer maintenant
à la troisième séquence de cette séance
d'ouverture et nous allons parler des
maires en première ligne dans les
tensions du quotidien les questions de
de sécurité la question des gestion de
risques qu'on évoquait
[Musique]
et nous allons à présent accueillir le
chercheur martial Foucault indirecteur
du Sevi post le centre de recherche de
Sciences Po qui va venir nous livrer les
conclusions de la quatrième enquête de
l'Observatoire de la démocratie de
proximité AMF c'est vipov Sciences Po
une enquête qui vous a permis martial
bonjour qui vous a permis d'interroger
près de
3700 maires qui expriment de nombreuses
inquiétudes liées à la crise de
l'énergie nous l'avons largement
développé mais pas seulement il y a
plusieurs faits majeurs que vous avez
noté dans cette enquête c'est à vous
oui bonjour merci merci pour cette
invitation merci Président
c'est un partenariat qu'on a mis sur
pied entre Sciences Po et l'AMF depuis
près de près de 4 ans je voudrais
peut-être commencer par remercier
l'ensemble des mers qui ont pris une
trentaine de minutes parfois un petit
peu plus pour répondre à cette enquête
votre votre concours est très précieux
parce que sinon nous pourrions pas
mesurer aussi finement que on essaie de
le faire à la fois votre état d'esprit
puis un certain nombre de sujets qui
nous nous oblige à regarder
attentivement ce qui est votre réalité
alors dans cette dans cette enquête nous
avons je vais prendre un visuel si ça
veut bien fonctionner voilà
un ensemble de sujets autour de
préoccupations cela a été répété depuis
l'ouverture du congrès
quatre sujets ressortent de cette de
cette enquête tout d'abord on observe ça
a été dit et répété mais je crois qu'il
faut insister
sur la grande difficulté qu'on les met
pour trouver élaborer penser des
réponses parfois pratiques aux pratiques
face à cette inflation énergétique dans
dans l'enquête nous nous voyons que la
première solution avancée c'est celle de
réduire l'amplitude horaire l'intensité
de l'éclairage mais aussi dans les
bâtiments municipaux les écoles les
crèches les installations culturelles
mais au fond les mers même si ils
répondent que ça sera la première action
ils sont conscients que cela ne suffira
pas sur le plan budgétaire donc il y a
une inquiétude qui est une inquiétude de
cet hiver mais budgétairement
probablement aussi au long cours sur
plusieurs exercices budgétaires deuxième
sujet c'est la question moi qui me
semble essentiel et que j'essaye avec
mes équipes de
d'interroger à la fois du côté des élus
mais aussi sur des grands échantillons
de français c'est quel est quelle est la
culture politique dans ce pays vis-à-vis
de la décentralisation et je crois que
nos résultats montent dans cette enquête
tiennent très forte demande de plus de
d'autonomie demandée par les maires
autonomies bien sûr en termes de liberté
locale autonomie financière et que les
Français en parallèle ou à l'image de ce
qu'indique les mères sont extrêmement
demandeurs non pas
d'un mouvement Girondins comme on aurait
pu dire il y a deux siècles les Jacobins
contre les Girondins non c'est beaucoup
plus simple la demande elle est celle de
réfléchir si aujourd'hui le principe de
la devise républicaine l'égalité
territoriale et bien est-ce qu'elle
produit de l'efficacité dans l'action
publique locale et on voit que les
maires près de 80% des mers préfèrent
que les décisions soient prises au plan
très local même si on doit abandonner ce
principe d'égalité territoriale si au
rendez-vous de cet abandon c'est
l'efficacité qui est de mise à l'inverse
on voit bien que les raisons qui
poussent aujourd'hui un certain nombre
de maires à être
inquiet par rapport à un grand mouvement
de décentralisation c'est c'est une
question qui là encore est tout à fait
légitime c'est celle de la péréquation
entre les territoires les plus riches et
les territoires les plus pauvres donc je
crois que ça c'est un c'est
véritablement un sujet à mettre en avant
troisième point les tensions
démocratiques après la séquence des
élections présidentielles législatives
on a souhaité vérifier auprès de chacun
et chacune d'entre vous si ce que vous
avez observé en termes de résultats
électoraux la montée des blocs extrêmes
est-ce que cette montée avait des
répercussions dans votre commune est-ce
que vous observez finalement un
durcissement des opinions politiques
est-ce que les citoyens ont de plus plus
de difficultés à discuter entre eux et
nous observons que près de un mers sur
deux nous indique avoir observé depuis
qu'ils ont été élus cette plus grande
difficulté entre les citoyens il y a une
forme de politisation à l'extrême sur
des sujets qui habituellement n'étaient
pas politisés et cela a des conséquences
dans dans le climat municipal et
j'aborde ce dernier point sur les
violences à l'endroit des élus alors
peut-être
en détail vous voyez sur la question
énergétique bon la préoccupation elle
est très très grande on voit sur ce
schéma en bas à gauche le niveau de
préoccupation si je devais le résumer
plus de 8 mètres sur 10 sont très
préoccupés par la situation énergétique
qui est à la fois une difficulté dans
les solutions je l'ai évoqué tout à
l'heure vous avez ici à droite ce qui
indique les maires dans notre enquête
dans les actions privilégiées pour faire
face à cette inflation des prix de
l'énergie vous voyez que dans un premier
temps ce sont les questions d'éclairage
moi j'ai été frappé d'observer que
beaucoup de mer dans un certain nombre
de verbatifs nous indique qu'il ne
souhaite pas aller dans une situation
qui les mettrai très en difficulté en
particulier vis-à-vis des écoles
vis-à-vis des crèches parce qu'on parle
du chauffage on parle d'électricité mais
aussi une question alimentaire
l'inflation alimentaire je crois que ça
a été rappelé ce matin sur la situation
des finances publiques locales où on a à
la fois une contrainte pour certes les
équipes municipales mais aussi une
contrainte pour les familles et donc il
y a il y a un double effet qui qui est
en train de se mettre en place cette
préoccupation pour finir sur ce premier
point c'est une préoccupation que l'on
n'avait pas observé avec la même
intensité lors de la crise covid et donc
je pense que on un élément de très
grande inquiétude de la part des mers et
c'est un sujet qui je pense doit être
surveillé comme le lait sur le feu
deuxième
élément sur cette culture politique de
la décentralisation
j'ai revu parce que vous avez ici à
travers ces deux illustrations
l'élément qui nous cette complexité dans
la relation entre les collectivités
territoriales les municipalités et
l'État central à la question est-ce que
les maires ont l'esprit
décentralisateurs bon vous voyez que
près de 55% des maires considèrent que
l'État doit complètement renoncé aux
compétences qu'il a des centralisé et je
crois que le sujet il est pas tant sur
le rayon on peut discuter est-ce qu'il
faut aller un peu plus loin sur un
certain nombre de politiques est-ce
qu'il faut revoir l'architecture entre
les compétences des départements des
régions des municipalités non ce qui est
me semble-t-il dissimuler derrière cette
réponse
c'est l'idée d'être cohérent entre la
nature des compétences et la nature des
ressources pour les exercer pleinement
moi je ne cesse de répéter que la
décentralisation c'est au fond que
l'affirmation d'un principe de
responsabilité la responsabilité
politique et dans les pays qui n'ont pas
cette structure unitaire pour les
citoyens
faire vivre la démocratie municipale
c'est effectivement pouvoir juger
évaluer cette responsabilité politique
exercée par les mers et les choses comme
plutôt bien faites on a un rendez-vous
tous les six ans pour effectivement
évaluer et que le jugement des citoyens
puisse se porter à l'endroit des mers le
deuxième sujet qui a aussi un rapport
avec cette culture ou cette absence de
culture politique de décentralisation
c'est le reproche que font les mers sur
un trop grand nombre de doublons entre
les services de l'État et ceux des
collectivités territoriales j'avais
rappelé il y a il y a deux ans quand on
avait mené la précédente enquête
en septembre 2020 que derrière la crise
covid on a beaucoup parlé de la
réhabilitation de la relation entre le
maire et le préfet
j'aurais peut-être un son de cloche
légèrement différent en indiquant que
oui cela était vrai en particulier dans
des départements où les sous-préfectures
sont devenus sortes de navire fantôme où
les moyens de l'État sont absents et
donc des sous-préfectures qui ne
fonctionnaient pas donc évidemment la
relation mère préférée a été réhabilitée
pleinement réhabilitée dans d'autres
situations où on a encore alors certes
il y a eu un effort un certain nombre de
fonctionnaires territoriaux ont
repris place dans les sous-préfectures
mais danser dans ces cas de figure je je
reconnais et j'observe et les maires
confirment cette impression qu'il y a
encore trop de doublons trop de doublons
entre ce que l'État souhaite faire et
qui au fond ne devrait pas faire d'un
point de vue normatif et ce que les
maires et président de PCI pourrait
pleinement assurer pour ne pas être trop
long
un petit moment d'auto promotion et vous
me pardonnerez parce que je n'aurais pas
le temps de tout développer mais dans
cette dans cet ouvrage qui était le
fruit des enquêtes avec l'associant des
maires de France je j'indiquais que la
France est un pays unique au monde
au sens où nous sommes le seul pays
capable de rassembler près de 1 million
de personnes au moment de l'élection
municipale 960
000 pour être très précis de personnes
qui vont se mobiliser pour faire vivre
la démocratie municipale donc faire acte
de candidature sur l'ensemble des listes
aux élections municipales c'est pas
anodin un million de personnes
rapportées au collège électoral de
personnes de plus de 18 ans en âge de
voté et bien cette je dirais cette cette
vivacité cette manière de rendre vivante
la démocratie municipale elle doit être
l'occasion également de s'interroger sur
ce qui pourrait mettre en difficulté ou
ce qui pourrait affaiblir cette
démocratie municipale et l'une me
semble-t-il l'une des dimensions qui
nous faut prendre très au sérieux c'est
ce que j'évoquais tout à l'heure ce
n'est plus une opposition entre
centralisateur décentralisateur non
aujourd'hui il y a une demande très très
forte des citoyens pour plus
d'efficacité
et cette efficacité on pourrait se dire
alors est-ce qu'il faut l'inscrire comme
une devise au fronton des mairies c'est
pas ça le sujet c'est dire que la la
demande de l'exercice d'une
responsabilité elle est jugée
aujourd'hui au gré de ce critère de
l'efficacité et parfois oui je crois
qu'il faut le dire il ne faut pas
hésiter à le rappeler l'efficacité peut
être contraire avec l'égalité mais c'est
tout d'une question de mesure c'est
toute une question de mesure c'est à
dire que ce qui a été évoqué parfois je
sais pas si c'est une neuve langue ou
une une lubie de mettre en avant la
différenciation moi j'ai vécu pendant 8
ans dans un pays le Canada pays
décentralisateur où il y a une structure
qui est totalement différente de la
nôtre
l'égalité elle est totalement assurée
sans qu'elle vienne
mordre sur le terrain de l'efficacité
donc je dirais que on voit bien qu'il y
a une aujourd'hui un moment peut-être
important je sais pas si le président de
la République et l'exécutif plus
largement souhaiteront établir une
feuille de route autour de ce que serait
un mouvement décentralisateur mais je
crois qu'il faut il faut prendre très au
sérieux cette demande de plus grande
efficacité et aujourd'hui l'architecture
du territoire l'architecture
administratif ne permet pas pleinement
de répondre à cette demande d'efficacité
et pour pour terminer
un élément sur les violences parce que
j'expliquais tout à l'heure qu'il y
avait des tensions démocratiques se
durcissement des opinions c'est pas le
seul élément explicatif de ce qu'on
observe de cette évolution de cette
croissance des violences à l'endroit des
élus alors les violences elles sont
elles sont pas toujours physiques
heureusement elles sont parfois très
symboliques mais c'est la portée de ce
symbole qui doit nous obliger à
comprendre si le mal est et
contournable ou pas là vous avez à
l'écran l'ensemble des situations qui
pour moi est un bon indicateur de ce qui
se passe réellement dans les communes je
sais que il y a eu un certain nombre de
dispositifs qui ont été mis en place
d'ailleurs à l'initiative de l'AMF avec
la gendarmerie nationale pour
accompagner un certain nombre d'élus se
sont pas seulement les mères ce sont
l'ensemble des équipes municipales et
que dans nos enquêtes
ou on attend une déclaration du
répondant du maire c'est très compliqué
de révéler des situations de violence
donc je pars du principe c'est une
hypothèse de travail qui a une
sous-déclaration dans nos enquêtes
d'accord malgré cela ce que j'observe
c'est voyez il y a des phénomènes
nouveaux c'est-à-dire que si je prends
les atteintes au bien de la commune pour
21% des maires qui nous ont répondu et
l'échantillon est vraiment représent de
l'ensemble des strates de population des
communes 21%
de nouvelles situations d'atteinte au
bien de la commune 19% d'incivilités
nouvelles en l'espace de deux ans je
considère que si on retrouve vraiment
tous ces résultats dans le détail je
vais vous demander malheureusement leur
tour d'aller à la conclusion et
peut-être justement le sentiment des
mères sur l'insécurité dans leur mandat
dans leur fonction en conclusion sur ce
sujet de des incivilités vous je vais je
vais dire les choses plus simplement
progression nette depuis deux ans des
formes de d'incivilité d'agressivité
d'un politesse et donc c'est un
sentiment extrêmement dur pour les mères
qui bien souvent je crois qu'il faut le
dire n'osent pas nécessairement déposer
plainte au regard des représailles
qu'il pourrait subir donc je crois que
ça c'est un point à accompagner et
deuxième et dernier point on a aussi je
crois que c'est le chiffre qui m'a le
plus surpris sur ce terrain des
violences c'est le nombre de maires qui
aujourd'hui déclare subir des violences
sur les réseaux sociaux et sur Internet
en faisant la distinction de à la fois
des réseaux sociaux utilisés de façon
institutionnelle c'est le compte de la
commune ou le compte personnel et
j'observe que quand il y a violence
agression menace sur les réseaux sociaux
ça va bien au-delà simplement du maire
mais c'est aussi son entourage familial
et ses plus proches qui subissent
l'ampleur de cette de cette violence
merci martial on retrouvera tous les
résultats de cette enquête sur le site
de l'AMF et ils sont toujours très très
précieux puisqu'on on peut mesurer une
évolution aussi dans le temps de
l'opinion des mers par rapport aux
problèmes d'actualité merci beaucoup
Marcel Foucault pour ce tableau de
l'État aussi des élus de leurs
inquiétudes vous parliez à l'instant du
sujet des violences et oui le maire est
en première ligne face aux citoyens face
à leurs attentes parfois face à leur
colère mais aussi leurs incivilités ou
leur violence regarde
un projet territoire et pas du tout pour
vivre ces situations là menace de mort
coup et blessures plus d'une centaine de
domiciles et de voitures personnelles
d'élus ont également été pris pour cible
bonsoir à toutes et à tous les hommages
se multiplient donc après la mort du
maire de signes c'est un village du Var
en deuil depuis maintenant deux jours
Jean-Mathieu Michel 76 ans a été
renversé par une camionnette dont il
voulait vers baliser les occupants le
maire de signe c'était vraiment c'était
un maire sur le terrain voilà qui qui se
promène qui se balade dans sa ville et
qui intervient et ça se termine mal et
il perd la vie donc oui on se dit que ça
peut arriver beaucoup plus vite qu'on ne
le pense et à n'importe qui voilà donc
ça a été un traumatisme pour tout le
monde c'était un monsieur qui avait un
certain âge et qui pour autant s'engager
avec avec passion comme comme souvent et
qui était un élu rural ça veut dire
qu'une fois de plus c'était quelqu'un
qui n'avait pas la totalité des services
pour l'accompagner comme on peut l'avoir
dans une ville de taille moyenne ou de
grande taille en Seine-et-Marne un maire
recevant des coups de poing en Côte-d'Or
un autre blessé à la tête
palpable des coups sont donnés 950
et le 9 mai c'est pas moins de 80% des
victimes qui sont des élus municipaux
des chiffres qui invitent à la réflexion
très clairement je pense que s'il y a de
plus en plus d'agressions sur les sur
les mers et les élus municipaux c'est
justement parce qu'ils sont plus proches
et que ce sont les derniers qui sont
réellement accessibles à la population
et je conçois aussi qu'un certain nombre
de mes collègues se mettent parfois en
retrait voir des sites de renoncer on
éloigne de plus en plus les lieux de
décision du local les mers sont de plus
en plus
des saisies un certain nombre de
compétences par contre ils sont
responsables de tout au regard de la
population donc on décide de moins en
moins on est quand même responsable de
tout ces gendarmes sont des négociateurs
formés par le GIGN ils apprennent au
maire à réagir face aux insultes ou aux
intimidations indignation et colère chez
les maires face aux nombreux agressions
dont ils sont victimes certains espèrent
que la justice prenne ses
responsabilités aujourd'hui c'est devenu
d'une banalité d'agresser un élu je
pense qu'il faut que cela devienne
courante que les sanctions soient
lourdes je pense qu'on a pas l'arsenal
législatif il faut aussi changer
de la population sur les élus parce
qu'on est quand même victime nous aussi
de tous pourri entre guillemets c'est on
est des locataires de la République on
est pour un temps donc tout ça est aussi
à travailler dans les fondements de
l'institution et de la République
voilà la responsabilité des élus la
responsabilité des maires et j'invite
Muriel Fabre la secrétaire général de MF
agression des luttes tensions et
difficultés du quotidien Le Maire en
première ligne
merci merci beaucoup Mesdames et
Messieurs chers collègues je voudrais
tout d'abord remercier martial Foucault
pour cette enquête claire concrète et
précise qui finalement marque le constat
que nous faisons nous au quotidien
effectivement nous souhaitons
massivement un renforcement des libertés
locales parce que la défense des
collectivités c'est la défense des
libertés locales notre association
veille sans relâche à ce que la
décentralisation garantissent aux
communes une réelle autonomie de gestion
des affaires locales car oui vous le
savez on l'a assez souvent rappelé la
décentralisation aujourd'hui est mise à
mal il s'agit de faire confiance aux
collectivités sont comme le répète notre
président ou encore notre premier
vice-président sont paternalisme ou son
tutelle déguisés nous avons aujourd'hui
plus que jamais besoin de marques de
confiance et ces marques doivent
commencer par des actes les réponses
actuelles ne sont pas à la hauteur des
enjeux il est urgent d'agir pour
maintenir la qualité l'efficacité et la
continuité de nos musique locaux car
nous sommes des élus de proximité les
mers sont en première ligne ce live
valable sur la plupart voire sur
l'ensemble des sujets qui touchent les
Français nous savons l'adaptabilité
accrue de nos collectivités notre
présence au quotidien auprès de nos
habitants et je n'ai aucun doute comme
vous que nos collectivités continuent à
être ce lien si précieux sur nos
territoires nous sommes le premier
guichet pour nos concitoyens quel que
soit le domaine un problème de logement
un souci d'inscription à l'école une
difficulté de voisinage c'est le maire
qu'on vient voir une difficulté
d'installation de commerce la fermeture
d'un bureau de poste c'est le maire
qu'on vient voir et si nous n'avons pas
de médecin ou encore pas de crèche c'est
encore une fois le maire que l'on vienne
voir si nous avons ou pas la capacité
d'agir après deux ans de gestion de
crise sanitaire qui ont été fait
d'inédits d'imprévus d'adaptation l'été
2022 a été particulièrement rude pour
les mères confrontés aux diverses cat
naturel je pense bien évidemment aux
incendies mais également aux périodes de
sécheresse de grêle ou encore d'orage
violents là encore une nouvelle fois
c'est le maire qui est en gestion
directe et immédiate cardurgence
n'attendent pas
cela est aussi le cas sur le front de la
sécurité là aussi une fois de plus les
mères sont en première ligne il demeure
le premier échelon de dialogue et
d'action avec les citoyens cette
proximité est d'autant plus personnelle
et palpable dans les communes de petites
tailles bien évidemment car le maire est
bien souvent seul ou alors avec une
petite équipe et il doit exercer son
champ de compétence un petit peu démunie
le maire et le niveau d'écoute et de
confiance cela a été particulièrement
mis en exerme dans le film introductif
et effectivement dans l'enquête du
sevlipof ils le sont sur le front de
sécurité et le paie souvent en
s'exposant eux-mêmes au danger vous
l'avez rappelé effectivement monsieur
Foucault les élus victimes d'agression
de toutes formes et bien ces élus là
c'est en recrudescence on le constate
avec l'AMF puisque entre 2020 et 2021
c'est plus de 47% d'augmentation de ses
agressions là et c'est fait aujourd'hui
doit être systématiquement sanctionné
en fait nous constatons une augmentation
des incivilités cela gangrène le
quotidien de nos Français il s'agit
évidemment de fait de petites
délinquance on pense au tapage nocturne
de dégradation au rodéo au dépôt sauvage
finalement pris individuellement et sous
le regard de la gravité pénale ça reste
des effets mineurs mais leur
accumulation la forme d'impunité qui les
entourent cristallisent aujourd'hui
l'attention et les tensions cela
commence aussi parfois par des mots du
maire pour faire cesser et cela finit
par des coûts notre évolution sociétale
aujourd'hui couplée au sentiment que
tout peut être résolu tout de suite ce
désir qu'on a d'immédiateté ni avec
l'essor du numérique on peut aujourd'hui
tout avoir avec son smartphone mais
effectivement on peut pas forcément tout
avoir sur l'ensemble du territoire et
puis une autre cause celle de plus en
plus manifeste et des compensées de
remise en cause du principe d'autorité
le premier niveau d'exercice aujourd'hui
c'est le niveau communal la plus petite
entité administrative aujourd'hui
considérant l'éloignement des services
publics dans nos territoires depuis des
décennies cette distance entre
l'exécutif et le citoyen et bien
aujourd'hui c'est le maire seul qui
incarne l'autorité de la République et
forcément il répond là individuellement
sur sa circonscription de phénomène qui
le dépasse bien souvent alors
aujourd'hui non mesdames et messieurs
pas de fatalité il nous faut agir
effectivement il nous faut une réponse
ferme et concrète à l'ensemble de ces
situations le rôle pivot des mers doit
être réaffirmé et s'il y a bien une
chose que les mères disposent c'est bien
la volonté la volonté de servir le
collectif la volonté d'agir pour le
collectif alors nous allons agir aux
côtés de l'État sur la tranquillité la
sécurité publique en disposant des
outils législatifs et des moyens pour
agir continuer par exemple à mieux
coordonner les efforts dans le cadre du
continuum de sécurité ce dernier reste
trop souvent mal défini et peine à
trouver une homogénéité sur le
territoire et puis apprendre à mieux
travailler ensemble en particulier en
matière de prévention de délinquance
renforcer les CI SPD les CLSPD pour que
ce soit des véritables lieux d'instance
de dialogue et de proximité et puis
aussi développer les moyens
technologiques adaptés en particulier
sur la vidéoprotection et l'amélioration
aussi des conditions d'exercice des
policiers municipaux et des gardes
champêtres et puis nous serons également
bien évidemment attentif à la réalité
des annonces qui ont été faites pour la
locmi c'est à dire une efficacité
opérationnelle des moyens déployés et en
fait il nous faut effectivement une
solution adaptée une solution
opérationnelle sur le territoire mais le
territoire c'est la métropole et les
outre-mer et nous devons aussi agir par
anticipation sur les grandes transitions
en cours et qui vont fatalement ajouter
de l'attention localement il nous faudra
nous former à gérer les crises du
quotidien et les crises majeures mieux
se former à la gestion des incivilités
grâce à la formation des négociateurs
régionaux de la gendarmerie nationale et
de la formation de la police nationale
vous avez pu le dans le film mais c'est
aussi en se préparant que les mères
aujourd'hui construisent la résilience
face aux crises majeurs qui nous font
face nous l'avons vu pendant le covid
nous l'avons vu lors des catastrophes
naturelles nous l'avons vu lors des
actes terroristes nous l'avons vu lors
des attaques cybers nous préparons aussi
grâce au plan communaux de sauvegarde
aux réserves communales de sécurité et
aux exercices incendies alors oui
mesdames et messieurs s'ennuyer les
difficultés il faut rester optimiste de
nombreux élus sont dans leur premier
mandat et développent énormément
d'énergie au quotidien pour leur commune
lafluence d'ailleurs cette année à notre
104e congrès montre que la dynamique de
mobilisation elle est nationale les
initiatives locales pour faire face aux
tensions dans le dialogue et la
construction sont à l'oeuvre les débats
du forum sécurité ce matin en sont par
exemple
la nouvelle dynamique de la commission
sécurité et prévention de la délinquance
en est un autre et pour les mois à venir
nous aurons des propositions
constructives au profit de nos
administrés la fonction des lieux
locales est une fonction passionnante
pleine de sens et enrichissante nous
sommes des élus de proximité nous sommes
des élus du quotidien nous sommes élus
de l'urgence nous sommes des élus de la
gestion de crise nous devons être
respectés et effectivement les sujets et
les enjeux qui nous attendent sont
nombreux on le voit transition
écologique crise économique lutte contre
l'incivisme transformation numérique
nous serons évidemment être à la hauteur
car la volonté sera présente notre
optimiste sera notre compagnon d'efforts
et nous aurons la réussite par l'action
je vous remercie
merci beaucoup Muriel Fabre secrétaire
général de l'AMF vous en avez parlé à
l'instant dans votre discours la gestion
de la sécurité c'est aussi celle des
risques la gestion des catastrophes qui
ont été nombreuses en 2022 inondations
sécheresse mais aussi feu de foraine
nous allons conclure cette séance
d'ouverture du sans quatrième congrès
des maires en accueillant ceux qui ont
été sur le front de ces catastrophes
mais d'abord retour en images sur ces
catastrophes qui ont marqué ces derniers
mois
en Gironde
la tempête alex est en train de
s'abattre sur les Alpes-Maritimes images
impressionnantes pour nos déchets qui
traversent la vallée de la Vésubie et
ravages tout sur son passage directement
commune a subi un véritable bombardement
on a au moins une dizaine de maisons qui
ont été emportées et il y en a plus
d'une cinquantaine qu'on a dû évacuer
dans les fondations menaces péril et le
seul moyen de rejoindre notre commune ce
sont des moyens héliportés parce qu'on
est entièrement isolé actuellement on
est coupé du
la Guadeloupe durement touchée par Fiona
la tempête Fiona est en train de
déferler sur l'île depuis diluviennes en
trois heures il est tombé 200 mm de
pluie par an
il va falloir reconstruire à la fois les
hommes et des femmes qui habitent ici il
faut qu'on a avec un moment donné de se
dire qu'on est du courrier
d'environnement d'écologie de
développement durable et que dans les
fêtes voilà le résultat encore la
stupeur est totale jamais l'une de
beauté n'avait été confrontée à un
épisode orageux aussi brutal le vent
amène souffleur rafale jusqu'à 224 km/h
à Marignana en Corse du Sud la forêt
brûle en Gironde dans trois jours
l'incendie dans le secteur de Landiras
un ravagé 7400 hectares on était avec un
front de 600 mètres de flammes de
flammes de 30 mètres de haut c'était
apocalyptique il y a des bourses qui
sont entourés de la forêt et qui
malheureusement deviennent dangereux
c'est le véritable catastrophe c'est
quelque chose qui vous prend trip il y
avait longtemps que ce type de sinistre
n'était pas arrivé et bien il est là
aujourd'hui il est là
après un été marqué par des feux
particulièrement intenses en Gironde du
Finistère au Jura aussi 72000 hectares
de végétation détruits au total
des images spectaculaires des drames
humains et environnementaux et pour cet
hommage à ceux qui ont été sur le front
des catastrophes de 2022 monsieur le
président David Lisnard vous avez
souhaité ce moment
vous avez souhaité ce moment et en
particulier aussi l'occasion de rendre
hommage à ceux qui ont été sur le front
de ces catastrophes mais aussi
l'occasion de rappeler que l'AMF prend
des outils c'est qui peut et capable de
répondre et on va appeler
Eric menaci le maire de Trèbes et
Sébastien Leroy le maire de
Mandelieu-la-Napoule qui animent le
nouveau groupe de travail de l'AMF sur
la gestion des risques j'invite aussi à
nous rejoindre sur cette scène des mères
qui ont été victimes de ces incendies
comme Philippe Chalopin que l'on a vu
tout à l'heure mère de Baugé en Anjou en
Maine-et-Loire mais aussi Nathalie le
yombre mère d'Audenge en Gironde sur le
Bassin d'Arcachon et puis nous
accueillons ce qu'on a vu au front du
feu voilà les héros de cette année nous
accueillons le lieutenant-colonel
Jean-Paul bosseland secrétaire général
de la Fédération nationale des
sapeurs-pompiers
on est un peu dit bien sûr
s
après toutes les épreuves qui ont été
vécues récemment en France ces images
conviennent de devoirs qui sont très
spectaculaires mais aussi des acteurs
qui sont au front qui sont au quotidien
dans la défense de la population et des
territoires vous avez tout dit c'était
quand on a souhaité ce moment dommage et
ce moment aussi de de projection de
prospective dans les épisodes qui
étaient évoqués tout à l'heure il faut
ajouter aussi les épisodes de grêle je
pense notamment dans l'Allier où j'ai vu
des villages des communes dévastées par
la grêle et à chaque fois je l'évoquais
d'ailleurs dans mon propos tout à
l'heure les mers sont systématiquement
en première ligne c'est pas une formule
c'est c'est pas un effet de langage
c'est une réalité auprès des habitants
pour pendant la catastrophe pour éviter
qu'il y ait des victimes puis pour la
réparation la réparation physique la
réparation morale la réparation
matérielle et nous l'avons vécu pour
du coup dans dans nos communes on l'a
vécu avec Sébastien Leroy façon
dramatique par des inondations et des
crues éclairs qui a fait 20 morts le 30
octobre 2015 et je crois qu'il faut
comme toujours en sortir plus fort alors
pour cela l'association des maires de
France les maires de France souhaitaient
rendre hommage à tous ceux qui
s'engagent et en particulier bien
évidemment nos formidables
services de protection civile qui sont
une fierté dans le monde entier les
services de protection civile français
et rayonne et en particulier les
services de pompiers et ils nous
souhaitions apporter son autre soutien
notre soutien et permanent par le
financement des 10 il faut il faut le
rappeler mais notre soutien aussi
affectif et notre admiration pour les
pompiers qu'ils soient professionnels
qu'ils soient engagés ou volontaires aux
sapeurs-pompiers puis soutenir bien
évidemment les services de l'État qui
qui parce que c'est eux qui nous
accompagnent c'est dans ce sens là que
ça fonctionne les services de la
préfecture les services d'association
spécialisés ou pas qui moyenne tous les
services des communes les agents
municipaux et les intercommunalités qui
sont admirables et puis marquer notre
soutien à tous les maires il est vrai
que ces incendies de Gironde de nous ont
particulièrement interpellés mobilisés
aussi et
ce soutien révèle la réalité humaine que
sont ces catastrophes et tout d'abord le
traitement humain nécessaire et puis
parallèlement on essaie d'anticiper une
catastrophe n'est jamais identique à une
autre mais l'exercice l'anticipation
permet d'avoir les bons réflexes permet
de préserver des vies humaines permet de
faire du citoyen le premier maillon de
la performance civique face au risque
majeur qui est souvent très soudain et
c'est ce que nous allons mettre en
exergue à travers les travaux du groupe
de travail que préside nos collègues ici
présents et tout au long de l'année 2023
je le disais tout à l'heure et j'ai dit
dans la salle plénière réunie nous irons
vers les communes vers les associations
départementales pour mettre en place les
les prédispositions qui permettent
d'affronter les crises et les risques
majeurs donc c'est à la fois de
l'anticipation de la méthode et puis de
la reconnaissance humaine aux
professionnels et aux amateurs qui
s'engagent face au risque majeur
et pour conclure cet hommage je donne à
présent la parole et au secrétaire
général de la Fédération nationale des
sapeurs-pompiers le lieutenant-colonel
Jean-Paul bosseland
merci Président je voudrais tout d'abord
excuser Grégory Alliot le président de
la Fédération nationale des
sapeurs-pompiers de France et vous
l'avez dit bien sûr c'est au nom de en
tant que secrétaire général de cette
association qui regroupe 285 000
adhérents mais aussi maire d'une commune
de Haute-Savoie que je tiens à vous
remercier président pour pour ce temps
et aussi pour tout le travail qu'apporte
la MF auprès des pompiers de France mais
les mers et les pompiers sont au
quotidien sur le terrain dans nos
fonctions respectives de directeur des
opérations de secours et de commandant
des opérations de secours merci pour
votre soutien monsieur le Président sur
la campagne